Okay,
I told you at the beginning of the class
that I started working on this material
partly because I was interested in why
people were so inclined to to go to any
lengths to protect their belief systems.
I wanted to understand and I knew that
those were systems of value,
right?
That that belief system is something
that enables you to ascribe value to
things so that so that you can act in
the world towards things in a way from
things roughly speaking,
and I've already made a case to you that
belief systems regulate people's
emotions but not
not as a consequence of decreasing their
death,
anxiety or anything like that,
or even directly decreasing their their
threat sensitivity or uncertainty,
but more specifically by helping them
orient themselves in the world so that
what they do matches what they want in
the social environment,
and it's an important set of
distinctions because the emotional
control that belief systems allow is
mediated by success in the social
environment.
That's the crucial thing.
It's not.
It's not directly.
It's not as if you're holding a belief
system and that's directly inhibiting
somehow your emotional responsivity.
It's more that you share,
you have a motive,
orienting yourself in the world so that
other people can understand what you're
up to so that you can cooperate and
compete with them without conflict and
the fact that you can do that without
conflict and maybe even with
cooperation.
That's what regulates your emotion,
so it's not only the fact of the beliefs
belief system,
it's the fact that it's shared with
everyone else and so people are willing
to defend their belief systems because
they're defending the territorial
structure that enables them to make
sense of the world and then to act out
making sense of the world with everyone
else around them.
Now,
then the question arises,
what if two different groups of people
have different belief systems?
What do you do in a situation like that?
And one answer is you capitulate.
Another answer is that you fight.
Another answer might be that you come to
some consensus about how the difference,
those different belief systems might be
mediated so that you can inhabit the
same territory without subordination or
without conflict.
But if you're going to come together in
an agreement,
you can't do that simply by abandoning
the belief system because the belief
system is what orients you in the world.
And so the negotiation is very tricky
and because of that,
it often ends up in subordination or
conflict.
Another question that might arise out of
that rat's nest of questions is if you
have belief system a and you have belief
system B and they're in conflict,
is there any principles that you can use
or any guidelines you can use to take
the belief systems apart to under to try
to understand what might be of central
value in either of them or both so that
if you do bring them together or even if
one supersedes the other,
that there is some evidence that they're
predicated on principles that are
actually viable.
And of course that brings up the
question of what constitutes viable
principles.
And I got interested in that more
particular question because when the
Cold War was raging,
there were two ideological systems set
up in the world.
Roughly speaking.
There were of course more,
but we can simplify it for the sake of
argument down to two and one was
predicated on the communitarian
principles that were put forward by Marx
and the other was a consequence of the,
I would say,
western,
individualistic free market capitalist
democracies,
roughly speaking,
and then you might ask yourself,
well,
were those only,
was that only a difference of opinion?
Right,
because that's the central question.
It was just a difference of opinion.
If what's underneath it is arbitrary
then a,
it doesn't matter which system wins
roughly speaking be.
There's no right and wrong in the
discussion,
right?
It's that that would be something that
would be more akin to a postmodern
claim.
It's just group a puts forward their
claims to power and Group B puts form
their claims power and they're both
equally valid and while have add are
fundamentally because there's no way of
solving the problem,
but it struck me that,
that I didn't think that we should leap
to that conclusion so rapidly and so I
started to investigate.
I think I started to investigate the
substructure of Western thought.
Not so much communist thought because I
thought of communism as an interloper on
the scene.
It was a system that wasn't devised and
formalized until the late 1900,
late 18 hundreds and I didn't see it as
part of what you might describe as
organic development.
There's no mythologies,
so to speak,
at the basis of,
of the communist perspective.
And one of the things that's very
interesting is that although those ideas
were roundly defeated by the end of the
20th century,
they're making a comeback so rapidly
that it's almost unbelievable.
Know I got an email from a medical
student yesterday at the University of
Toronto and now their courses that they
have to take the mandatory.
These are social justice courses include
modules on equity and equity as equality
of outcome that they're pushing.
People are having the equality of
outcome notion pushed on them in
mandatory training and universities
everywhere.
Again,
and equity isn't equality of
opportunity,
equality of outcome.
You know,
that was the central dictum of the
Communist states in the 20th century.
It's like,
what the hell?
How did we get back to that again
already so.
And the idea being is if there isn't
absolute equality of outcome within an
organization that the thing is corrupt,
it needs to be restructured from the
bottom up.
And then the question of course is who
decides that outcomes are equal by what
means and with what groups?
Because you can,
you can produce an infinite number of
groups of people with equally validly in
some sense,
and you're never going to get equality
of outcome across the infinite number of
ways that you can parse up society into
groups.
It's not even technically possible
unless everyone has nothing.
So anyways,
these are obviously very powerful ideas
and the mere fact that they killed 100
million people already are more in the
20th century wasn't enough to put them
to rest.
Anyways.
So back to the main theme.
Is there something.
This is the main question.
Is there something,
is there a set of ideas that Western
civilization is predicated on that are
more than just bloody opinion?
That's the question.
Because if there isn't,
well then what do you.
What do you do about that?
It's arbitrary.
He was just holding it for no reason
whatsoever.
It could be a different system.
There's no reason to stick with it.
All of those things like it takes the.
It takes the core out of it.
When that was neat,
just claim right.
He said,
you take the core metaphysical
presupposition out from underneath
Western civilization or any civilization
for that matter and the whole thing
loosens chickens,
shakes and crumbles.
Well for nature.
The metaphysical presupposition was God.
Well then the question of course,
well,
what even does that mean?
And it on one hand it means,
I suppose adherence to a dogmatic set of
beliefs,
but then you might ask yourself,
well,
is there something else that it means?
It means at least the hypothesis of some
transcendent value.
It means at least that.
So you know,
Nisha announced the death of God and so
one of the consequences of that
Dostoevsky was working on exactly the
same set of ideas and in crime and
punishment in particular,
which is a book I could.
It's a necessary book.
That's the thing is there's a number of
books that were written in the last
hundred and 20 years that you really
have to read.
Crime and punishment is one of them and
I think the Gulag archipelago is another
and probably beyond good and evil is
another,
but Dostoevsky.
Nietzsche were writing in parallel.
It's remarkable how much their their
lives intertwined and Nisha knew more
about Dostoevsky than than is generally
don't.
There's been some recent scholarship
indicating that,
but Dostoyevsky's book,
crime and punishment,
he has his main character.
Riscal Nichol decides that he's going to
commit a murder and he has very good
justification for the murder and
Dostoevsky is very good at this.
He,
he puts his characters into very,
very difficult moral situations and
gives them full justification for
pursuing the,
the,
uh,
for pursuing the pathway that they're
pursuing.
And so ruskell Nikolov,
he's broke and starving.
He wants to go to law school.
His sister's about to prostitute herself
rough,
roughly speaking by marrying a guy that
hates her,
that she hates and that,
and he has contempt for her,
at least acts in that manner.
He's trying to rescue his mother as
well,
who's also in dire financial straits.
He,
he,
he goes to a pawnbroker to pawn his
meager position so that he can continue
to scrape by and she has this nice,
I believe it's her niece that's not very
bright,
who she basically treats as as a slave
and his horrible too,
and so the care,
the pawnbroker has this money.
Ruskell Niqab is in dire need.
He thinks,
look,
I'll just killer because why the hell
not?
I'll take her money.
She's not doing any good with it.
Anyways.
I'll free your niece who's just working
as a slave.
She's got all these other people tangled
up in her pawnbroker schemes.
All that will happen is the world will
be a better place and the only thing
that's holding me back is conventional.
Moral cowardice and Dostoevsky has his
character in crime and punishment go
through days,
hours,
hours and days and weeks of intense
imagination about this rationalization,
about this,
trying to justify himself,
placing a metal outside,
placing him self outside the law so that
he can perpetrate this act and telling
him self with all the best nihilistic
arguments that the only possible thing
that could be holding them back is an an
arbitrary sense of indoctrinated
morality and so dusty Esky explores that
he does commit the murder and then of
course all hell breaks loose because
things don't necessarily turn out the
way that you want.
He gets away with it.
However,
while he gets away with a technically
because no one knows he did it,
but he doesn't get away with it in
relationship to his own conscience and
so that the rest of the book explores
that.
Well,
Dostoevsky,
I believe it was in crime and
punishment.
Although he makes the same point in many
of his books.
He makes a very fundamental point,
and this is the kind of point that that
I think that people who haven't
investigated these matters down,
this particularly particular literary
and philosophical pathway,
never grappled with Dostoevsky,
said straightforwardly if there's no
god,
so if there is no higher value,
let's say if there's no transcendent
value,
then you can do whatever you want and
that's the question that he's
investigating and you see,
this is why I have such frustration say
with people like Sam Harris,
this sort of radical atheists because
they seem to think that once human
beings abandoned their,
their grounding in the transcendent,
that the,
the plausible way forward is with a kind
of purist rationality that automatically
attributes to other people equivalent
value.
It's like I just don't understand that.
They believe that that's the rational
pathway.
What the hell is irrational about me
getting exactly what I want from every
one of you whenever I wanted at every
possible second.
Why is that are irrational and how
possibly is that more irrational than us
cooperating?
So we can both have a good time of it.
I don't understand that.
I mean,
it's as if the psychopathic tendency is
irrational.
There's nothing irrational about it.
It's pure naked self interest.
How is that irrational?
I don't understand that.
Where?
Where's the pathway from rationality to
to an egalitarian virtue.
Why the hell not every man for himself
and the devil take the hindmost?
It's a perfectly coherent philosophy and
it's actually one that you can institute
in the world with a fair bit of material
success if you want to do it so I don't
see.
To me,
I think that that the universe that
people like Dorkins and Harris inhabit
is so intensely conditioned by
mythological presuppositions that they
take for granted.
The ethic that emerges out of that as if
it's just a given,
a rational given,
and this of course precisely niches,
observation as well as Dostoevsky's.
That's snitches observation.
You don't get it.
The ethic that you think is normative is
a consequence of its of its of its
nesting inside this tremendously lengthy
history,
much of which was expressed in
mythological formulation.
You wipe that out.
You don't get to keep all the
presuppositions and just assume that
they're rationally axiomatic there.
The rational to make a rational
argument,
you have to start within an initial
proposition while the proposition that
underlies western culture is that
there's a transcendent morality.
Now you could say that's a transcendent
morality instantiated in the figure of
God.
That's fine.
You could even call that a
personification of the morality if you
want to.
If you don't want to move into a
metaphysical space.
I'm not arguing for the existence of
God.
I'm arguing that the ethic that drives
our culture is predicated on the idea of
God and that you can't just take that
idea away and expect the thing to remain
intact midair without any foundational
support.
Now you don't have to buy that,
but if you're interested in the idea,
then you can read Nicha because that's
what he was trying to sort out and it
wasn't only nature.
He came to that conclusion.
It was many people have come to that
conclusion,
but I think the two who've outlined it
most spectacularly were Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky.
Nietzsche is an unbelievably influential
philosopher.
You know,
I don't think there was anyone that was
more influential
during the entire course of the 20th
century accepting a very,
very tiny handful of other people
accepting the scientists.
We won't bother with their,
with their discussion.
You could put marks in that category.
You could put Freud in that category
partly,
but after that the list starts to get a
lot thinner,
you know,
so maybe there's 10 people up,
but now level and Dostoevsky of course.
I think if,
if you ever,
if anybody ever prepares a list of the
top 10 greatest literary figures in the
world,
he would be in the top 10 list and now I
think he's perhaps second to Shakespeare
and maybe above Shakespeare in my
estimation.
So these aren't trivial people we're
talking about and they weren't dealing
with trivial issues.
Well,
so then the question might be what's at
the bottom of the idea of a transcendent
value?
And I want to want to approach that
staying out of the metaphysical domain
as much as possible because you can
claim anything you want from a
metaphysical perspective and that's a
big problem.
And so people will say,
well,
why come up with a hypothesis of God?
For example,
God can be anything.
There's a satire.
The Flying Spaghetti Monster,
right is classic satirical
representation of a deity that the
atheist types used to buttress their
arguments and fair enough,
you know,
as a satirical idea,
it's pretty damn funny,
but there's things about this that
aren't the least bit of music.
And the thing that's not amusing as
well.
What if anything,
is our culture predicated on,
okay,
so what happened?
Well,
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky put this forth,
this set of propositions and out of
Dostoyevsky's line of thinking to some
degree grew Solzhenitsyn soldier units
and documented the absolute horrors of
equity predicated Soviet society.
You know,
and we don't teach,
we don't learn about that.
Write this I don't understand,
is that what happened in the 20th
century on the radical left end of the
spectrum is not well documented.
Students don't learn about it.
Why the hell is that?
We learned about World War Two.
We learned about what happened in the
Holocaust.
And Fair enough,
we absolutely should,
but nobody knows.
It's a mystery to everyone.
When I talk about what happened in the
Soviet Union,
and that's absolutely appalling,
that's to say nothing about what
happened in China,
which was equally horrible.
The system didn't work.
It was predicated on the wrong values.
Unless you think that that sort of thing
means worked,
you know,
because you have to define that as well,
but it collapsed under its own weight
after it killed tens of millions of
people.
That doesn't really end.
Still Rich,
not like Russia has recovered.
It doesn't seem to me like that's a very
good definition of worked.
Now whatever we're doing in the West
seems to work for all of its flaws and
the question is,
are we just deceiving ourselves?
Is it just arbitrary power,
politics and opinion,
or is there something at the bottom of
it?
So when Solzhenitsyn wrote the Gulag
archipelago,
he believed that the Russians would have
to return to Orthodox Christianity to
find their pathway forward and that's of
course has made him into a reactionary
in the eyes of many of his critics,
but that is perhaps what is happening in
Russia.
Although it's very difficult to tell
because Putin also seems to be using his
affiliation with the Orthodox Christian
Church as as it means to consolidate
power,
so the situation in Russia is unclear,
but a religious revival if that's
happening in Russia and perhaps it
isn't,
but if it is happening,
is something that unfolds over decades
and even centuries,
so it's not an easy thing to evaluate
when it first starts to happen,
but Solzhenitsyn drew the same
conclusions that dos Dsq did
fundamentally,
not not in exactly the same way,
but very,
very close.
He,
he believed as far as I could tell,
that unless people were willing to
adhere to some sort of transcendent
value,
that they had no protection against
pathological ideologies and no
protection against the murderous
impulses that came along with them and I
found his work at unbelievably.
I found his right.
Incredible,
powerful,
incredible.
I don't know how you can read that book
and not draw that kind of conclusion.
I think people who criticized soldier
nets and have never read the damn book
because that book is like.
It's like going into the ring with
Mohammed Ali and being pummeled to death
for half an hour,
you know,
you don't recover from it that easily.
So
then young branched off of nature and so
niches.
Idea was that people would have to
create their own values roughly speaking
and I think that's where niches is.
We is his weakest because it isn't
obvious to me that people can create
their own values and I think he fell
into.
I don't want to be a casual critic of
nature because that's always dangerous
given that he probably had an Iq of 260.
You know,
I mean,
he was way the hell out there in the
stratosphere.
It just,
when you think you've understood what he
was talking about,
you can be bloody well sure that you
didn't,
but it does seem to me.
And he was running out of time.
He died young and he was trying to solve
this problem in a rush I would say.
And he hypothesized that people would
have to become Superman overmanned
roughly in order to deal with the death
of God.
And that idea sort of branched off into
Nazi propaganda because that's in some
sense with the Nazis were trying to do
with their promotion of the of the
perfect area.
Now it's a mist,
it's a misappropriation of nature in my
estimation.
And it was partly because his sister who
is a perverse creature,
I'm a,
what would you say,
doctored his work in such a way so that
it was more easily appropriated by the
Nazis,
but there is some danger in what he said
too,
because the question is,
well,
if you're going to transform yourself
into the,
into the giver of values,
what stops you from inflating yourself
into something like a demigod and just
pronouncing what the values are going to
be.
So that's a problem.
You know what you're going to replace
tradition with yourself.
Well,
there's dangers in that because there's
nothing to keep you humble.
That's,
that's the most appropriate objection.
There's nothing to keep you humble.
And those things can spiral out of
control very rapidly.
And they did say in the case of Hitler,
I mean it's easy to blame what happened
in Germany on Hitler,
but that's a.
that's a big mistake because it was a
dialogue between Hitler and the German
people,
right?
Hitler didn't create himself.
It was cocreation.
He said things.
People listened and told him back what
to say,
and then he said them and they listened
and they told them back what to say and
it looped until he was the mouthpiece of
their darkest desires.
Now that's a.
that's a game he was willing to play,
but you can't think about that as it
isn't like Hitler created Nazi Germany,
Hitler and the Germans,
cocreated,
Nazi Germany.
Now,
when a leader gives our articulation to
the imagination of the population,
that's what a leader does,
and you know you could say that,
well,
Hitler,
maybe Hitler filtered what the Germans
were telling him through a particular
lens because he had no shortage of
resentment and desire for revenge in his
own heart.
You know,
it's not like his life was a spectacular
success be before he became a political
activist and he was brutalized very
badly in world war one and he didn't get
to pursue his primary dream,
which was to be an art student in
Vienna,
and he had applied three times and got
rejected all three times and so it was
bitter about that.
He was basically living on the streets
after World War One.
It wasn't the world's happiest person
and I'm sure he carried a fair bit of
resentment in his heart when he was in
the trenches in world war war one at in
one experience that he had.
All of his friends were killed by a
mortar when he had wandered off to go do
something else.
So you know,
it's hard to even imagine what something
like that would do to you,
but I can tell you when you're the only
survivor out of 20 people,
that's also going to give you an
enhanced sense of your own specialness.
Because the alternative is just to think
about how God damn arbitrary.
The universe really is so,
so
young.
Studied nature in in great detail and he
was particularly interested because
young had his finger on the central
problems all the time,
right?
Because he was a great psychologist and
he was listening to what people said and
he was an a staggering genius as well
and so like Nietzsche or Dostoevsky or
social nets and he was that kind of
prophetic type I would say,
and he understood as well.
Perhaps what was wrong with niches
formulation,
the idea that people could only create
their new,
their own values and that's what would
replace the lacking.
Found the foundation that was now
lacking under Western civilization
itself.
And he came to his conclusion,
I would say through Freud because Freud
started analyzing parts of the human
cognitive process and content that
people hadn't attended to before in any,
in any great detail.
And that was primarily dreams.
You know,
the idea of dream analysis I suppose is
one of Freud's perhaps Freud's major
contribution to modern western thought.
The idea was there was something to
dreams and I suppose what I did is said,
hey,
look,
isn't it strange we have this whole
other form of thought that we engage in
at night and it speaks in the language
that we don't really understand and so
what the hell is that?
And you can say,
and many modern people do,
dreams are of no significance or even
that they're random processes,
which is an absurd proposition obviously
because they're by Terrell,
whatever they are,
they're obviously not random,
so.
So Freud's idea was that there was some
something in dreams that was
informative,
so that's his.
Now he had a method for describe for
extracting out from the dream what the
dream purported to represent and he
outlined that great deal of detail in
the interpretation of dreams and if you
want to read one book by Freud,
I would highly recommend that one.
It's a very long book and it's very
detailed,
but Freud does it extraordinarily
comprehensive analysis of the way that
dreams work.
Now he made the because because he had
brought a theoretical framework to bear
even on his investigation into dream
structure.
He concluded that dreams were
essentially wish fulfillments,
and that's where young and Freud
disagreed.
He also believed that the primary
motivating factor of human beings with
sexual,
and now that's a tougher one to toss
aside because even if you're a Darwinian
rather than a Freud Ian,
you're going to obviously support the
proposition that sexual motivation among
any living creature is going to be one
of the highest order motivations because
otherwise creatures don't reproduce and
prevail over the long run.
So the question is,
is that is that the ultimate source of
motivation?
And in some sense the answer to that has
to be yes.
Well,
Freud wanted to make that in some ways
the sole source motivation,
and I'm oversimplifying,
I hate to do that in relationship to
Freud because he was not as simple
minded.
Character young had a dream once,
if I remember correctly,
that Freud and jung were excavating a
basement and so freud had outlined in
Freud had already discovered the
basement,
let's say.
So that would be the unconscious
structure of the psyche and young broke
through into another basement that was a
multi chambered place.
So many,
many,
many rooms and I suppose what drove
young and freud apart was the
proposition that there was a hell of a
lot more going down,
going on down there.
Then had already met the eye and they
broke on the idea that the sexual
impulse was primary.
Roughly speaking,
they broke when you wrote a book called
symbols of transformation,
which is actually.
There's.
There's three books that I know of that
are sort of like maps of meaning.
One is symbols of transformation.
One is a book by Eric Norman called the
origins and history of consciousness
and the third and the third one,
while his maps of meaning,
they're the same book.
They're just like,
they're trying to solve the same problem
from three different directions.
They're all attempts to address the same
problem.
And so symbols of transformation was a
book that you wrote about the fantasies
of a schizophrenia American woman,
and he was.
He was trying to relate her fantasies to
these old mythological ideas and young's
idea essentially.
And this is an idea that was shared by
people like piaget.
So we were not going to say that you and
I just pulled this idea out of the air,
was that the,
the birthplace of mythic mythology and
literature for that matter was the dream
that they share structural that they
share,
they share,
they share what mode of information
presentation,
and it's a relatively radical
hypothesis,
but,
but given that they both,
they both represent
hm
dreams,
dreams and mythological representations
share and essentially narrative
structure and they use their literary
like,
you know,
I mean it's not so unreasonable to
notice that a dream at night is like the
movie that you play in your head and
it's not unreasonable to note as well
that the dreams that you have at night
bear a relationship to the daydreams
that you have during the day.
It's a form of cognition.
It seems like an involuntary form of
cognition.
No,
and that's a very strange thing.
So young thought about the dream as
nature,
speaking of its own accord,
roughly speaking.
And so his idea was,
well,
when you,
when you sleep,
you dream,
but the dream happens to you.
It's not something that you create the
way that you don't even think about
creating it because I might say,
well,
what are you thinking about?
And you'll say,
I'm thinking about whatever it is and
you'll take credit in some sense for
thinking that because it seems like a
voluntary activity,
but what happens at night is that you
think,
but you think in voluntarily and so what
would say is that means that something
is thinking in you and that's a
perfectly reasonable way of looking at
it and this is one of the things that's
uncanny about the cycle analysts as they
were willing to take their observations
to their logical conclusion.
There are things that think in you.
What are those things and what are they
thinking and why are they thinking it?
Now,
if you do dream analysis,
and this is a tricky thing because who's
to say if your damn analysis is correct?
Right?
It's very difficult to understand that.
If you.
If you do dream analysis with someone,
you generally have them lay out their
dream and then you ask them when they're
going through their dream a second time,
they lay out their dream and you can
kind of get a picture of it,
and then they lay out their dream a
second time and as they go through it,
every time they mentioned a detail or a
character,
you ask them what that reminds them of
and the hypothesis is that the dream is
presenting an image or an idea that's
associated with a network of ideas and
then if you can expand on the network of
ideas as you go through the dream,
you can elaborate on the dream.
You can expand it upwards and you can
start to see what it might be attempting
to put forward.
Now,
Freud's idea was that the dream knew
what it was doing,
but that its content was being
suppressed and oppressed by an internal
sensor.
So the dream had to be sneaky about what
it was saying because it was going to
deliver a message that the person didn't
want to hear.
That that was tied up with his idea of
repression,
but that's not young's idea.
See,
young's idea was different.
He said,
no,
no.
The dream is trying to tell you what
it's trying to tell you as clear as it
can.
That's just the best it can do,
and so you could think of the dream,
and this is I believe,
the right way to think about it.
The dream is the birthplace of thought.
The same way that artists are the
birthplace of culture.
It's exactly the same process.
It's that your mind is groping outward
to try to comprehend what it has not yet
comprehended and it does that first by
trying to map it on to image and it's
doing that in the dream and it's
somewhat incoherent and and,
and well,
let's stick within coherent because it's
not yet a full fledge thought.
It's the birthplace of thought.
It's a fantasy about what might be,
and then if you can grip the fantasy and
share it with other people,
then maybe they can elaborate upon it
and bring it into being with more
clarity than it would be if it merely
existed.
As the precursor of a thought in your
imagination now cause you anxiety,
idea two was okay.
You think you think in words,
where the hell do those thoughts come
from while they just spring into my
head?
While that's not much of an answer,
they just what?
Pop out of the void.
Is there some sort of precursor to the
development of the ideas?
Is there a developmental pathway?
So here's an image.
This is the Buddha.
There's calm water,
there's a lotus.
The roots go all the way down to the
bottom of the lake.
It's dark down there.
The roots are embedded in the dark
substrata at the bottom of the lake.
The plant moves upwards towards the
light that the water gets lighter and
lighter.
As you move upward with the root,
the flower manifests itself on the
surface and the Buddha sits in the
middle.
That's an image about how ideas develop.
They come out from the bottom of reality
and they push themselves up towards the
light and they blast forward and
something emerges as a consequence.
That's what that image means and it's an
image.
The Golden Buddha that's sitting in the
middle of the Lotus is an image of the
perfect person.
You could think about the gold Buddha
who sits in a triangle as exactly the
same thing.
That's the eye on the top of the pyramid
is they're all the same ideas and what's
the idea that's trying to burst forward
how to be in the world?
Well,
what other idea would burst forward
because it's the only problem that you
really have,
right?
How should you manifest yourself
properly in the world?
It's everyone's question.
It's the ultimate question.
It's been the ultimate question since
the beginning of time and we'd been
working out that idea forever,
first of all,
merely by acting it out and then by
representing the actions and then by
representing the representations and
spiraling all that together.
So I started looking developmentally.
I thought,
okay,
maybe these idea have roots,
and this was partly predicated on the
observation from Dostoevsky and niches
and so forth that there did seem to be a
necessary pattern in moral,
in morality.
Did it seem to be unnecessary pattern?
It wasn't arbitrary.
It was a.
It was a representation of the specific
mode of human beings and it isn't
something that's just imposed on you by
your culture's not something that's just
learned,
it's intrinsic in you and it's manifest
in the culture at the same time and
there's a dial and and and there's a
dialogue between those two things.
Culture and nature were both with the
ideas embedded,
trying to make,
make,
make the proper articulation of that
spring forward in each individual,
and that's only to say these aren't,
these aren't radical propositions.
Your nature strive so that you can
manifest yourself properly in the world.
Culture strives to aid you in that
endeavor.
Is that.
Is there something about that?
That's,
that's,
that's dubious validity.
What else would it be doing?
Working for your death,
hardly working for your destruction.
While you could see that maybe when
culture becomes pathologized,
but to the degree that it's able to
maintain itself across long periods of
time,
it obviously has to be striving in some
way for the man of,
for your individual manifestation so
that you can survive and flourish.
So there's a,
there's a,
there's a co creation of the human being
going on through nature and through
culture and while and then perhaps with
your own,
with your own voluntary will
participating,
whatever the hell that is,
something we don't understand at all and
are and are prone to dismiss because of
that.
So then I learned about piaget.
Piaget had some very interesting ideas
and I think I've told you already what
piaget was up to.
He wasn't a developmental psychologist.
He didn't even regard himself as a
psychologist.
He wanted to reconcile science and
religion.
That's what he was doing through his
entire bloody life because it drove him
crazy when he was an adolescent and he
didn't think that he would be able to
survive unless he could bring those two
things together.
So he's working on the same problem.
And so one of the things that piaget,
who was very prone to observation,
he was an ecologist of human beings.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And ecologist as a scientist who studies
animals by watching their behavior
rather than studying them under
laboratory conditions.
And he got very interested in the
spontaneous emergence of morality in the
play of children that was so smart.
They're so smart.
That idea that you know when kids come
together and unify themselves towards a
particular goal,
so in play that are morality emerges out
of that and that that morality,
and I've mentioned this before,
there's a morality in game one there.
There's a morality in game two,
there's a morality in game three.
What's common across all those
morality's as a matter of morality.
And so the matter morality emerges from
the particular morality's that are
embedded in particular cooperative
situations.
We could say cooperative and competitive
You can expand that out to die.
You can expand that out biologically to
some degree,
to the idea of the dominance hierarchy,
right?
Every social animal and even many
animals who aren't social are embedded
in a dominance hierarchy.
The dominant Turkey has a structure.
We couldn't call it a dominance
hierarchy.
Dominance hierarchy,
thousands of them across thousands of
years.
You extract out from all of them what
central to all of them.
That's the pyramid of value.
What's the.
What's the question?
What question do you need answered about
the Pyramid of value?
What's at the top
[inaudible]?
That's the ideal.
That's the eye.
At the top of the pyramid are the Golden
Buddha.
In the Lotus,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing as the crucifix,
paradoxically enough,
and that has to do.
It has to do with something like the
voluntary acceptance and therefore
transcendence of suffering.
It's something like that.
These are not arbitrary ideas.
They're deeply.
That's my case anyways.
They're deeply,
deeply,
deeply rooted in biology and culture.
They're there as deeply rooted in
biology as the dominance hierarchy is
rooted in biology and we already know
the answer to that.
The dominance hierarchy is been around
for 350 million years.
It's a long time.
You don't get to just brush off and say,
well,
morality,
some sort of second order cognitive
problem.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
I can.
I can tell you something about its
instantiation in your nervous system.
You have a counter at the bottom of your
brain that keeps track of where you are
in terms of your status and it bloody
well regulates the sensitivity of your
emotions.
So if you're at the bottom of the
hierarchy,
barely clinging onto the world,
everything overwhelms you and that's
because you're damn near dead and so
everything should overwhelm you.
You've got no extra resources anymore.
Threat,
you're sunk,
so you become extremely sensitive to
negative emotion and maybe also
impulsive so that you grab well the
grabbing is good and if you're near the
top in the dominance hierarchy and your
counter tells you that,
then your serotonin levels go up.
Your less sensitive to negative emotion,
you're less impulsive.
You live longer,
like everything works in your favor.
Your immune system functions better and
you're oriented at least to some degree
towards the medium and longterm future.
And you can afford that because all hell
is breaking loose around you all the
time.
And so then the question is,
is there a way of being that increases
the probability that you're going to
move up dominance hierarchies?
Well,
that doesn't seem to be particularly
provocative proposition unless you think
that it's completely arbitrary and
random and that you can think that if
you want,
but I don't think there's any evidence
for that whatsoever.
I mean,
we certainly have,
even for sexual selection,
we impose criteria.
They're not ram random and arbitrary,
so.
Okay,
so back to young.
So what was young trying to do?
Well,
he was trying to see,
see young believer that once we had
stopped populating the cosmos with gods
that they went inside.
That's a good way of thinking.
Well,
think,
think about it this way.
You know,
archaic person looks at the sky and uses
his imagination to populate the sky.
What's The sky?
Well,
it's the constellations.
It's the domain of the gods.
Well,
why?
because the gods are what are be,
are out there beyond your understanding.
Well that's what you see when you look
up at the sky.
So you populate the night sky with
figures of your imagination.
So the gods are the things that you
broadcast out of your imagination and
see spread over the world.
It's like the contents of your
unconscious are manifesting themselves.
When you encounter the unknown exactly
what it is,
that's exactly how.
How else could it be?
Right?
You're projecting your fantasy onto what
you don't understand.
That's how you start to cope with what
You populate the unknown with Daddy's.
Where did they come from?
They came from your imagination.
Well,
what happens when you take them out of
the world?
Do they disappear?
No,
they just go back into your imagination.
So that's where you dug down to find
them.
That's the same motif as rescuing your
dead father from the from or rescuing
your father from the belly of the whale.
It's the same idea is that the corpses
of the gods inhabit your imagination.
So where do you go?
If you need to revivify them,
you go into your imagination and that's
exactly what you did and this is no
secret.
If you read Young,
he tells you that's what he did.
He tells you that's why he did it.
It's not an interpretation on my part.
So then then the question is,
what's down there?
Is it just massive catastrophe or is
there something in it that's patterned
while young's proposition was that you
read?
Did you really discover the great
archetypes that guide human being by
investigating the structure of your
imagination?
When you thought about the imagination
in some sense,
at least in part as a manifestation of
your.
Of your biology?
Well,
yes.
What else would it be?
You know,
when I told you that story about my
nephew,
I believe right about him running around
as a night and then going off to have a
combat with the doors and the dragons.
It's like,
well where did that come from?
Well,
partly it came from his culture,
right?
Because he was at night and so obviously
that's a cultural construct,
but the thing is is that his imagination
is this structure that's looking for
things to fill it self with.
Just like your predisposition to
language,
you have a predisposition to language.
What is that we don't know.
What does it do?
It looks for things in the world to fill
itself with.
Right?
And if you're.
If you.
First of all,
when you start to learn how to speak,
you babble.
Every phoneme did.
Did you know that there's.
There's a lot,
there's a fire.
I was learning to speak an Asian
language.
There would be full names I couldn't
pronounce and vice versa,
an infant,
all of them.
They babble all the phonemes and then as
they start to learn the language,
they lose the ability to say a bunch of
them and only retain the ones that are
relevant to that language.
So a baby babbles all laying all
possible languages.
That's a way of thinking about it and
then loses the ability.
So that's a manifest that's you can see
there.
So you could say,
well,
you manifest the potential to be
possessed by all the set of all possible
archetypes.
It's built into your biology.
And then as you're enculturated in your
own culture,
the set of archetypes that manifest its
benefits themselves in that culture are
the ones that you pull in for your own
use.
So my,
my nephews running around like a night.
Well,
you know,
if he would have been born in the middle
of the Amazon,
he would have been running around with a
bow and know a poisoned Arrow in a bowl.
It's the same thing.
It's the same idea.
It's just trapped out in,
in different cultural dress and he,
he,
his little imagination was trying to
solve the problem.
How do you deal with the unknown?
Well,
what's the unknown?
It's these little devils that keep
biting,
jumping up on you and biting you and
they come out without.
So just killing them.
It's like cutting the head off the
hydro,
right?
Seven more grow.
Well,
what the hell good is it to solve one
problem when there's just a bunch more
problems that are come gonna come after
you.
And that's everyone's question.
That's the ultimate question of
nihilism,
right?
Why bother solving a problem if all
that's going to happen is that 20 more
problems are going to come your way.
Why not just give up and die while,
right?
It's a good question.
It's a.
it's a good question,
right?
Is the suffering so intense that the
whole game should just be brought to it
and that's another fundamental question
of existence and people who've become
truly malevolent answer that question in
the affirmative,
they say,
it's too much.
We should destroy it.
Now,
I wouldn't say they're precisely doing
it only for humanitarian reasons,
but you have to understand and
appreciate the logic.
It's not irrational.
That's the other thing.
It's not irrational to work for the
destruction of being.
It's not irrational.
In fact,
it might be the most rational thing you
could come up with.
It depends on your initial initial set
of presuppositions so young down into
the belly of the beast,
so to speak,
to to,
to,
to to see what lurks in the imagination.
He sees the birthplace of archetipal
ideas.
Well,
what are archetipal ideas?
There are patterns of a.
You could think about them as as
representations of patterns of adaptive
behavior,
and so then you might ask,
well,
where did they come from?
Well,
that's part of what I've been trying to
to,
to teach you about.
They evolved as far as I can tell,
right?
They evolved collectively.
Is that our society,
and this is the dominance hierarchy
idea,
dominance,
hierarchy set themselves up as a matter
of course,
they're the standard way that animals
organized themselves into territory.
Well,
okay,
human beings are watching those
dominance hierarchies since we became
self aware thinking,
what the hell are we up to?
What the hell are we up to?
What's and and there's a question that
lurks in there.
What constitutes acceptable power?
What constitutes acceptable sovereignty?
Who should lead?
Who should rule?
What should be at the top?
While we talked about that,
the Mesopotamians figured that out.
Speech and vision,
that's Marduk speech,
vision,
and the willingness to confront the
terrible unknown.
That's what should rule.
While what's that an arbitrary idea or
is that a great idea?
How could it be any other way?
Well,
that's what human beings are like and I
don't think that you can read the
Mesopotamian story and understand the
reference,
which isn't an easy thing to do and
failed to draw that conclusion.
Marta has eyes all the way around his
head.
He speaks magic words.
He goes off to fight,
tie amat the dragon of chaos.
Well,
what's that?
That's the Reptilian Predator that lurks
in the unknown.
While it is any of that it.
Is there anything about any of that that
stands in opposition to what you were pr
would presume if you were just analyzing
our situation from a purely biological
perspective,
we're prey animals.
We're predators.
We'd be threatened by reptiles forever.
Why wouldn't we use the Predator that
lurks in the dark forest or the water as
a representative of the unknown?
Why wouldn't we harness that circuitry?
We already have it at hand and even more
to the point,
how could we do anything else?
It's it makes perfect sense.
Well,
so then you might say,
well,
what would you want to be king?
You could say king of the world are king
of your own soul.
What do you want to subordinate yourself
to?
How bout your heroic willingness to
encounter the unknown and articulate it
and share that with people?
There is no nobler vision than that and
I don't see that.
It's merely arbitrary and so,
and it's not merely arbitrary too
because if you do that to the degree
that you do that assuming your society
isn't entirely corrupt,
you will be successful.
It will actually aid you practically.
You'll rise up above men,
you'll be selected by women,
you'll be admirable,
you'll be valued and and you know that
because if you look at the people that
you admire and value,
again,
unless you've taken a detour into dark
places and are,
are,
are possessed,
with admiration for people who are
working for malevolent purposes and for
destruction.
You just have to watch the people that
you admire and try to figure out what's
common across them and draw your own
conclusions and you can ask yourself to
when you're torturing yourself with your
conscience because you're not doing what
you should be and you know it.
What is it that you're torturing
yourself in relationship to?
You have a vision of your own ideal and
you torment yourself.
If you're not matching it,
what's the ideal?
Well,
you don't know,
right?
It's kind of incoherent and and poorly
articulated,
but that doesn't mean it isn't trying to
manifest itself and make itself known to
you.
It's really the purpose of religious
education is to make that ideal
articulated well.
We've lost that.
It's not a good thing.
Okay,
so I talked to you about the
Mesopotamian story and I talked to you
about the Egyptian story and what I
thought it meant and it's a bit of an
elaboration on the same theme because it
says,
well,
the hero isn't only the.
The Daddy,
the transcendent pattern,
let's say that goes out into the
unknown,
cuts it into pieces and makes the world
that's not good enough because it only
deals with the terrible mother.
That's one way of thinking about it,
but there's a terrible father to.
Once culture gets instantiated in large
scale and the Egyptians had that
problem.
Two problems,
chaos.
Second problem,
pathological order.
Well,
structures tend towards pathological
order.
The Egyptians laid out why that set
right?
Seth is the evil advisor of the king
who's lurking in the background all the
time,
trying to tear the structure down for
his own malevolent purposes.
So now and then that overcomes the
structure and destroys the and what
rigidified and makes malevolent the
entire social structure,
so a degenerate into safe,
fascist totalitarianism,
something like that,
and especially being a threat since
we've had highly organized societies.
Then the hero ends up in the underworld
and has to come back and do direct
combat without malevolent force at the
price of his own consciousness.
Right?
Because the horse gets one of his eyes
destroyed.
It's no bloody joke to face the forces
that make a culture rigid and
malevolent.
So there's an addition to the hero
archetype.
Two things happen.
One,
you go out and you conquer chaos and you
make order out of it,
but the second is you take pathological
order,
recasted into chaos and then allow it to
reemerge and you do that.
Not In some arbitrary sense,
but in tandem with your rescued father.
And that's I guess in part what niche to
MC missed as far as I can tell is he
didn't.
He knew that he knew of the death of
God.
Perhaps he didn't know that it had
happened.
Many Times Murcia Eylea documented that
across many cultures,
but what you didn't seem to lay out,
at least in his vision of the superman
or the Overman,
was that it was a responsibility of the
person who wants to reverify the culture
to go down and rescue the damn culture,
which is what you're supposed to be
doing in university because your father
is lying dead in the libraries.
Right?
So you're supposed to be going in there
and taking that spirit out of the books
and manifesting it in your own being.
That's what the universities were four,
although I don't think that's what
they're for anymore.
So we talked about the Mesopotamian
story and we talked about the Egyptian
story and other people have documented
the emergence of hero mythology in
culture is far more diverse than the
ones that I'm exposing you to.
That was done most popularly by Joseph
Campbell,
but Campbell's like,
I don't think Campbell had a single idea
that he didn't derive from young.
And I'm not saying that in a.
In a critical manner,
because Campbell was good at standing as
a mediator between young and in a more
general population.
He did and that's,
that's a nontrivial accomplishment.
Seriously,
but,
but young is still the source of those
ideas and if you're serious about them,
that's the person that you have to go to
for that kind of knowledge.
So now I wanted to tell you some other
stories that are,
that are in some sense closer to western
culture.
They're the stories upon which Western
culture is actually predicated.
So I'm going to tell you,
well,
I'm not only Western story today,
I'm going to tell you a couple of
stories from genesis and I'm going to
tell you about the story of the Buddha.
I'm going to do that at the same time
because the story of the Buddha is
almost a perfect parallel structurally
speaking to the story of Adam and eve.
And so I want to show you that.
And you can decide for yourself if I'm
imposing a pattern on it because God
only knows,
right?
Or whether or not.
Once you have the key to understanding
the stories,
which I hope I provided you with,
with the,
you know,
the idea of the dragon of chaos and the
great mother in the great father in the
individual,
it gives you a Schema that you can use
to understand the characterizations of
great stories and as far as I can tell,
it works pretty much universally across
stories,
so,
so I want to read.
I want to walk you through those
foundational stories and I would say one
of the things to know about the way the
Bible is structured,
there's a couple of things you want to
know about it is that it was authored by
multiple people across extraordinarily
vast spans of time and then aggregated
by other people and sorted into
something that seemed to make sense and
so you can really think about it as a
Bible is a library.
It's a library of books.
It's not a book.
The library is organized a certain way.
That makes a kind of sense,
but it's not exactly as if anyone
decided what that sense would be.
It's the collaborative work of hundreds
and thousands of people across thousands
of years attempting to organize our
collective story into something that
something out of which the sense
emerges.
It's like human beings acted and then
they dram,
dreamed about how they acted,
and then they wrote down what they
dreamed about,
how they acted,
and then they organized what they wrote
about how they dreamed they acted,
and that's how that book came into being
and the information that's within it
emerged from the behavioral level
upward,
right?
Rather than being imposed top down.
Now there's a.
there's a feedback,
right?
Because if you understand how you act
and that changes how you act and so you
can't.
You can't avoid the top down feedback,
but a tremendous amount of the
information in there and this is why
it's revelatory information.
We don't know it's in there because how
we act as informative and then if you
represent how we act,
that's informative,
but the information came from how we act
from the representation of how we act
and then you might think,
well,
how did we learn how to act?
And the answer is,
we've been trying to figure out how to
do that for three point 5 billion years.
There's lots of information encoded in
our actions and in our social
interactions way more than we
understand.
So we're acting something out.
We don't understand what it is,
but we're doing our best to pull that
information upward,
partly by dreaming about it.
That's what you're doing at night.
You're trying to figure out what the
hell you're up to.
Well,
you don't know because you don't know
yourself in totality.
How could you possibly know?
Best you can do is dream yourself up and
then speak yourself into some sort of
articulated existence.
It's just an approximation because you,
whatever you is,
whatever you are rapidly supersedes.
Whatever you think you are.
That's why people constantly shocked
themselves.
You know,
if you were only what you thought of
yourself or wouldn't life be simple.
You'd know exactly what you were doing
all the time and you could even control
your own behavior.
Well,
good luck with that.
You can't do that for yourself much less
for other people.
So let's go through these stories.
So they're sequenced,
people are trying to make sense out of
them.
They're aggregating these stories from
all sorts of different places,
all sorts of different tribes,
all sorts of different times and then
trying to make them coherent without
losing the content and without doing
arbitrary editing.
And so part of the reason that the Bible
is full of internal contradictions,
it's for the same reason that a dream is
full of internal contradictions is if
you impose too much coherence on it,
you start losing the look.
Imagine you have an imagined that you
have a impressionist painting,
well it's messy and,
and,
and the,
the image emerges and you might say,
well,
we could replace that with a nice clean
line drawing or even a sequence of stick
figures and get the basic point across.
It's like,
well,
you would,
but you'd lose the richness.
The,
an articulable richness would be lost in
the premature attempt to bring logical
closure to the phenomena.
And so in fact,
we know already that that's maybe the
difference between dreams and waking
thought.
So waking thoughts,
sacrifices,
completeness for coherence,
right?
So whereas dream thought sacrifices
coherence for completeness,
and that's,
that's,
that's not something I'm saying
arbitrarily.
This is something that has been thought
through by people who've been thinking
this sort of thing through for a long
time.
Precise thought
excludes too much.
An imprecise thought is not sufficiently
coherent.
So we do both precise thought left
hemisphere linguistically mediated,
sequential,
logical,
incoherent,
but complete thought imagistic emotion
based,
right hemisphere.
The right hemisphere even has a more
diffuse structure.
It's like the right hemisphere is trying
to get a picture of everything.
Now it's not going to be a very detailed
picture because it's a picture of
everything full of contradictions,
but at least it's a picture of
everything.
And the left says that's not good enough
for precise action and it's not.
So we'll narrow that to precision,
but we lose the richness.
But you need both.
So there's an interplay.
Well,
the documents that the Bible is composed
of our half dream and half articulated
thought and they have the advantages of
articulated thought and the advantages
of the dream,
but also the disadvantages of both.
So to the degree that it's articulated,
it's in a dogmatic box to the degree
that it's a dream,
it's still incoherent,
but it's the problem is you have to.
You have to move through the entire
world even though you don't know it in
detail.
So you need detailed knowledge were
detailed,
knowledge is necessary and you need
vague but complete knowledge where
that's necessary.
It's an.
It's a very uncomfortable balance,
but we have to face everything even
though we don't understand anything
completely.
Now,
genesis,
the first stories in genesis are,
what would you say on identifiably?
Ancient.
God only knows how old they are.
The story of Noah.
Here's an interesting thing.
I know this guy who's a.
he's a Kwakwaka'wakw tribal member and
an artist who lives on the tip of
northern Vancouver Island and the
culture he comes from is about 14,000
years old,
something like that,
and maybe it's odd,
been unbroken for 14,000
years,
a very long period of time.
And He.
He's not literate.
This guy,
although he's very intelligent,
has a great memory and is also a great
artist.
And He's told me some of the stories
that have come down through the
Kwakwaka'wakw tradition,
and he was educated by his grandparents
who were original language speakers.
And he's an original language speakers.
There are many people like that left.
I think there's only 3000 in his
particular tribal group.
They have a story that's the flood story
that this except it's canoes and it
isn't a dove.
It's a cro.
But the damn story is exactly the same.
It's like,
well,
what the hell is up with that?
In fact,
at the end,
it's not a canoe.
It's a bunch of canoes that are tied
together and at the end the canoes all
break apart.
And that's why there are people all over
the world.
It's like the story of the Tower of
Babel,
which I'm going to talk to you about
today.
So
the reason I'm telling you that is
because the stories at the beginning of
genesis are extraordinarily old now.
So maybe he tells the same story that we
tell,
you know,
making the presumption that we are the
people who are,
who are part of this Judeo Christian
tradition.
And I know that that's not the case for
everyone
either.
He's telling the same damn story and it
emerged from a central point so long ago
that it's 20,000
years or 30,000
years or maybe 50,000
years since we moved out of Africa.
Something like that.
And the story has survived,
which is certainly possible because
oral,
you think,
can an oral tradition survive that long?
That's the wrong question.
Oral traditions always survived that
long.
What's radical is that they disappear.
Were the radicals.
The oral tradition is something that
stays the same generation after
generation.
So how much innovation do you think
there is in a small tribal group?
None.
That's why they don't have advanced
technologies.
They stay the same.
The stories stay the same.
So the idea that they can be transmitted
unchanged over thousands and tens of
thousands of years is really not a
debatable proposition.
It's the norm.
So either the stories emerged from a
central source and have never been lost
so that you can pick them up everywhere
or there's something about the stories
that automatically regenerates
themselves.
And I suppose it's a little bit of
column a and a little bit of column B.
It's like my,
my nephew,
when he perceived himself as a dragon
slaying night,
it's like,
well,
was that the continuation of an oral
tradition or was it something that he
spontaneously come up with?
And the answer is both.
Both.
The pattern was there.
He just had to see it and he saw it and
synthesize it and pr and encapsulated it
in his own imagination.
Well,
that's not much different than the oral
tradition being unbroken.
It's just a variant of the same thing.
I mean,
if you lose a story,
but everyone acts it out,
you can reconstruct the story.
Right?
And if everyone doesn't act it out,
then the culture dies because there's
some things about the story that you
have to act out if your culture is going
to survive.
That's the hypothesis.
And then that would be.
Well that would be where you would
search for ultimate values,
the stories that enable you as an
individual to flourish in such a manner
that your culture flourishes in a way to
enhance your flourishing.
Right?
That's the right way that you want to
organize things.
You know that's what you do inside a
family.
If it's functioning well,
right?
The family function so that every
individual benefits from being in the
family and that strengthens the family.
That's what piaget called and
equilibrated solution.
Technically speaking,
when he was looking for the origin of
moral ideas,
he came up with the idea of a
celebrated,
celebrated state,
and then it calibrated state is one.
The three of you are in iniquity,
abraded state if you all want to be in
that state and while you're in that
state,
the things that you're doing together
work better and they facilitate each of
your development,
right?
So it's the stacking of,
of,
of an ethical.
Have a set of ethical propositions so
that the individual benefits at the same
time as the group and you can.
You can increase that stacking.
We could say,
well,
it's not only that you want to organize
yourself so that all three of you get
what you want better than you would if
you were alone and so that you're
healthy.
And so the stacking also occurs all the
way down the physiological chain.
You want to be manifesting yourself in
the world so that you remain is
physiologically healthy as you possibly
can,
so your stress responses are properly
balanced and all of that.
And then maybe your equilla braided
state as well enough developed so it
doesn't just include the three of you,
it extends outward beyond you into the
greater community and things stacked
like that.
And that's if they get,
if they all get stacked up,
every level is stacked on top of each
other properly.
You have an equilibrated state and I
don't think that that's any different
than a vision of paradise.
I think those are the same thing.
So now the question is,
well,
can that happen?
That's a whole different story.
I mean,
it happens in your own life at those
times where everything comes together
for you.
You know,
it's chaotic and then everything snaps
together and you think that's exactly
right.
And it's unstable.
You can't maintain it.
It fragments again,
but that's what you're.
That's what you're working towards.
If you have any sense,
you're working towards that constantly.
And I think that's what music
represents.
It's the stacking of harmonious
patterns,
right,
that are playing themselves out in
being.
And you watch how people respond to
music.
The Orchestra is led by the leader.
Every different individual plays his or
her part.
They're organized into string sections
and horn sections and so on.
So you get individual subgroup,
group,
orchestra,
leader.
Then maybe you have people dancing.
Well,
so what does that mean?
So maybe it's men and women dancing in
front of that,
like a Viennese waltz.
So it's the harmonious stacking of
pattern.
Being in the background led by someone
who is making sure that the time is in
order and men and women arranging
themselves according to the patterns.
Right?
And everyone has a wonderful time when
that's happening and it's acting out,
acting out the proposition that all of
these levels of being can be stacked up
harmoniously at the same time and
everybody has a tremendously fun time
while they're doing it.
Maybe that's how you find a mate at a
dance and for exactly the same reason,
it's an optimal place to do that.
You see if there's someone that you can
be with with whom you can mutually act
out the patterns of being well,
we're all acting that out at a dance.
We don't know what we're doing.
We're having a good time.
Well,
yeah,
that's a little glimpse of paradise.
That's what that good time is.
Now,
the Bible stories before what happened,
what seems to happen is that you can see
there's two cataclysmic events at the
first part of that.
At the end of the first part of Genesis,
there's the flood,
so the prehistoric world is wiped out by
the flood,
and so the idea there in some sense
there's a bunch of ideas,
but one of them is there's a place in
history past which we cannot look and
that's absolutely true.
One of the things that's very strange
about human beings is that are written
civilizations.
The ones we have records of all seem to
have popped up somewhere in the
neighborhood of five to 6,000
years ago.
It doesn't matter where you look.
Right?
Central America,
China,
India,
Greece,
Egypt,
well it's all the same.
Six thousand years ago,
post.
There we were.
Well,
what happened before that?
the answer is we don't know.
Everything is obscured by the chaos of
history before that point and all that
emerged out of it,
so to speak,
are these incredibly ancient stories and
so we're going to walk through the
ancient stories and see what we can pull
out of them.
We've already done that with several,
so there are some representations of the
garden of Eden.
So this is by Hieronymus Bosch.
I don't know if you know who hieronymus
Bosch is,
but he's definitely worth looking up
because he was one strange character.
He was like,
I think he painted in the 15th century,
if I remember correctly.
He was like this 15th century version of
Salvador Dali.
His paintings are so uncanny that that
they're still shocking to the mortar
nih,
which is really something because it's
not easy to shock a modern person with a
visual image,
but Hieronymus Bosch will definitely do
that.
And that's his representation of
paradise.
There's some central structure in the
middle that's partly phallic and partly
chambered so.
And there's Adam and Eve united,
united by God.
So.
And there's one by Peter Paul Rubens and
it sorted the primordial lush landscape
that you might think about as the what?
The ancestral human home.
It's something like that.
A treat landscape.
Well,
why trees?
While we liked fruit,
we lived in trees.
Why not trees?
I mean even modern people have a very
powerful tendency to think about trees
is sacred.
You wouldn't get environmentalists tying
themselves to great,
you know,
Douglas firs and protecting them if
there wasn't some deep felt sense within
us that they're sacred.
Whatever that means.
Well,
trees are our home.
that's as close to sacred as you're
going to get.
So
okay,
so I'm going to read you something from
the book of Job and this is God
harassing job.
So I don't know if you know the story of
Joe,
but it's very interesting story.
And basically what happens with job is
that God and the devil have a bat,
which seems a little unreasonable side
for God,
but he gets to do whatever he wants.
So he has a bet with Satan roughly
speaking and says,
says,
well job.
He tells Satan that job is a good guy.
And that he's faithful to God and Satan
says,
yeah,
let me let me out and for awhile I bet
you we can do something about that.
And God says,
roughly speaking,
no are you could torture her all you
want.
He's going to stay faithful.
And Satan says,
well,
we'll have a baton out and soul,
God hands them over and what happens to
job?
It's like everything terrible that you
could imagine then happens to job,
right?
His,
his,
all,
his family dies.
All his possessions are destroyed.
He gets a horrible skin disease.
And so then he's sitting there by the
fire sort of scraping himself with bits
of broken pots and all his friends come
around and tell them that the reason all
this happened to him was because he
deserved it.
So it's perfect,
right?
It's,
it's like an ultimate suffering story.
It's a precursor to the idea of the
crucifix.
That's one way of thinking about it.
So.
And Joel has a chat with God and asks
him like Cain did roughly
what's going on,
and God attempts to.
He's irritated that job would even dare
to question him.
It's like he's God.
It's gets to do whatever he wants.
It's a very strange book.
Anyways,
this is one of the things that God says
to job well,
God is trying to justify himself.
I would say to job,
and the reason I'm telling you this,
you see is because so imagine that
you're trying to analyze a literary
work.
You might say,
well,
where's the meaning in the literary
work?
And the answer is in the words
word by word.
It's in the phrases,
it's in the sentences,
it's in the relationship of the
sentences to each other.
It's in the relationship of the
sentences within paragraphs.
paragraphs within the contexts of the
chapters and it's in the relationship
between the chapters and the whole book
and then the book in the whole culture.
So you can't.
It's not easy to localize the meaning.
It exists at all those levels,
symbol [inaudible],
and they all inform one another and what
that means,
and it's even worse than a book like the
Bible.
I want to show you a picture.
This is an amazing picture.
So let me tell you what this is.
So the Bible is the world's first
hyperlinked document.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
So what you have here.
So what you see at the bottom,
there's a line along the bottom and then
there's small lines coming down from it.
Okay?
Each of those,
the line has dots on it.
Each job is a is a verse,
okay?
And then there's a line associated with
the verse that's a varying length and
the length corresponds to how many times
that verse is cross referenced somewhere
else in the document.
And then these rainbow colored lines are
the cross references.
So now that's really worth thinking
about.
So then you think,
well that book is deep.
Well why is it deep?
Well,
let's.
Because every single thing in it refers
to every other thing.
It's connected.
Like your brain is connected,
like it's not a linear document.
And the thing is a book is a very
strange thing,
right?
Because when you or or even a story,
because when you lay out the story in
some sense,
you're like,
God,
you're outside of the space and time of
the story and so you can adjust the end
to make the beginning different.
You know how if you watch a movie and
then it's got a surprise ending,
it changes the beginning.
You thought the beginning was one thing,
but it isn't.
It's something else.
Well,
when you lay out a story,
you can fiddle with the story anywhere
in the story and so and you can also
make something that happens before
dependent on something that happens
after,
which is very strange and that's what's
happened with the Bible because people
have worked on it,
worked on it,
trying to synthesize it and make it
coherent and make it make sense.
And so they're continually connecting
everything that's inside of it to
everything else.
And so you end up with a document map
that looks like that.
So now,
so you think about that.
Everything is connected to everything in
that document.
Not chaotically meaningfully.
Just like your brain is connected in a
meaningful way,
it's not everything is connected,
everything is connected in a meaningful
way,
and then you think,
well,
where?
What do the stories mean?
And then the answer is,
well,
that's a hard question because all of
them are connected with each other,
and then there's all these different
levels of analysis and so you can pull
out meanings at one level of analysis
that aren't self evident at another
level of analysis.
Just like if you're listening to a
complex piece of symphonic music,
you can follow a baseline or you can
follow the strings or you can follow the
horns and they're all harmoniously
interrelated,
but they're also separable.
Okay,
so there is an image that lurks in the
Old Testament and the images,
the same image.
It's roughly the same image as the image
of Marduk confronting tie a mat.
So for example,
at the,
at the beginning,
God makes.
Here's,
here's how the beginning goes.
In the beginning,
God created the heaven and the earth and
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of God moved upon the
face of the waters and God said,
let there be light and there was light.
Okay,
so we got to look at the first few lines
here.
So this is God justifying himself to
job.
He says,
can you pull in Leviathan with a fish
hook or tie down its tongue with a rope?
Can you put a cord through its nose or
Pearson jaw with a hook?
Will it keep you begging for mercy?
Will it speak to you with gentle words?
Will it make an agreement with you for
you to take it as your slave for life?
Can you make a pet of it like a bird or
put it on a leash?
For the young women in your house,
will traders barter for it?
Will they divided up among the
merchants?
Can you fill it's hide with harpoons or
its head with fishing spirits?
If you lay a hand on it,
you will remember the struggle and never
do it again.
Any hope of subduing,
it is false.
The mere sight of it is over powering.
No one is fierce enough to rouse it.
Who is then able to stand against me?
Who has a claim against me that I must
pay?
Everything under heaven belongs to me.
Oh,
more computer trouble.
Now.
There we go.
I will not fail to speak of Leviathan's
limbs.
It strengthen it's graceful form who can
strip off its outer coat,
who can penetrate it's double coat of
armor who dares opened the doors of its
mouth,
ringing about with fearsome teeth.
It's back.
Has rows of shields tightly sealed
together.
Each is so close to the next that no air
can pass between.
They are joined fast to one another.
They claimed together and cannot be
parted.
It.
Snorting throws out flashes of light.
It's eyes are like the rays of dawn's
flame stream from its mouth,
sparks of fire shoot out.
Smoke pours from its nostrils from a
boiling
pot overboard burning reads.
It's breadth sets,
coles ablaze,
and flames dart from its mouth.
Strength resides in its neck,
dismay goes before it.
The folds of its flesh are tightly
joined.
They are firm and immovable.
It's chest is as hard as rock.
Hard is a lower millstone.
When it rises up,
the mighty are terrified.
They retreat before it's thrashing.
The sword that reaches it has no effect,
nor does the spear or the dart or the
javelin earned.
It treats like Straw and bronze like a
rotten wood arrows do not make it flee.
Sling stones are like chaff to it.
A club seems to it,
but a piece of Straw.
It laughs at the rattling of the Lance.
It's undersides or Jag had pot shirts
leaving a trail in the mud like a
threshing sledge.
It makes the depth churn like a boiling
cauldron and stays up to see like a part
of ointment.
It leaves that glistening wake behind
it.
One would think the deep had white hair.
Nothing on earth is it's equal,
a creature without fear.
It looks down on all that or haughty and
is king overall that are proud.
Well,
so what's God doing?
He's describing what he defeated in
order to create the world.
That's Marta can tie matt.
Okay,
so that's one reference like that.
Alright,
so now another reference like that.
This is from psalms 74.
Yet God is my king of old working
salvation in the midst of the earth.
Thou did break the CND pieces by thy
strength,
Thou dits chatter.
The heads of the sea monsters in the
waters vow did crush the heads of
Leviathan,
right?
That's the creature that we just heard
described.
Thou gave us to him to be food to the
folk inhabiting the Wilderness.
Now you remember,
so when Marta defeats Tye,
Maddie cuts her into pieces and makes
the world out of her pieces.
In here.
What's happening is that the force that
that encounters,
the Leviathan is able to break it into
pieces and feed everyone with it.
Now,
the reason I'm telling you that in
relationship to this is because and the
earth was what?
Without form and void and darkness was
upon the face of the deep.
Let me tell you a little bit about that.
Those lines before God's God begins to
create the world is Tohu wa Bohu.
That's from the Hebrew.
The word Tohu by itself means emptiness
or futility,
so there's a psychological element to
that hay and that emptiness or futility
in some senses.
What you confront when you're trying to
extract your life from the world.
It is used to describe the desert
wilderness as well.
Whoa,
whoa.
Who?
Chaos is the condition
that Barra ordering remedies.
Okay,
so there's the idea in the first verses
that this initial chaos is being ordered
and the order is what makes the world so
the.
It's,
it's,
it's standard cosmology order emerges
out of chaos,
and the thing that makes it emerges.
The word of God.
Now darkness and deep,
which is home in Hebrew,
are two of the three elements of the
chaos represented in Intoa,
Tohu wa Bohu.
The third is the form of this earth.
In the Enuma elish.
The deep is personified as the God
goddess time at the enemy of Martech.
Here it is the formless body of primeval
water surrounding the habitable world.
Okay?
So,
but we know tailem and out are the same
word,
or at least tatum was derived from
timeout.
So the idea that's presented at the
beginning of genesis is the same.
It's an abstracted and psychologized
representation of the story that the
Mesopotamians put forward.
So Yahuah is Marduk,
roughly speaking,
going out and conquering the dragon of
chaos and making order out of it.
And then there are these illusions later
say in job,
been in the psalms of him doing exactly
that,
conquering a primordial monster and
making the world out of its pieces.
While so what does that mean exactly?
Well,
it means that the highest ordering
principle is the spirit that goes out
into the darkness or the deep that
encounters the dragon of chaos because
of obviously Leviathan is a dragon and
defeats it and feeds the people as a
consequence,
while we are hunting creatures after
all,
and in order to establish our place in
the world,
we had to go out there and conquer the
dragons of the wilderness.
You might wonder,
why does a dragon breathe fire?
Well,
there's a bunch of reasons as far as I
can tell,
fire is all inspiring,
so fire and a terrible Predator or the
same thing because they both inspire.
All fire is transforming,
but predit like,
what's a good metaphor for being bitten
by a poisonous snake?
Well,
have you ever seen the wounds that a
poisonous stake produces?
If you're bitten by them,
it's like someone took your arm and
incinerated it,
and so the idea that a snake has fiery
breath is,
well,
let's call it close enough from a
metaphorical perspective.
Right now,
God is claiming to job that he's the
spirit.
That clique that clears the wilderness
and then builds order out of chaos and
because.
Because,
because he's the embodiment of that
spirit,
in some sense,
job has no reason to ever question his
moral decisions.
It's something like that in the story of
job,
but the point that that point we'll
leave aside because it's a more
complicated issue.
The point is that the writers of the
Bible are trying to dream up a
representation of the spirit of
civilization.
That's the right way to think about it.
You can think of Yahuah as the spirit of
civilization and what is that?
Well,
it's the thing that encounters the
wilderness and makes habitable order,
but then it's also the spirit of the
order itself and that's I think why in
Christianity there's a representation of
God the father because he's a
representation of the culture that's
generated after the chaos has ordered,
right?
You have the spirit that goes out into
chaos and slash orders and then you have
the spirit of the order and then the
spirit of the order and the spirit of
the ordering principle have to figure
out how to coexist.
That's partly what the Egyptians were
trying to figure out,
right?
There's a dynamic relationship between
the culture and the spirit that
generates the culture and then you might
also ask,
should the culture be superordinate or
should despirit that generates the
culture be super superordinate,
and the answer seems to be the emergent
answer seems to be that the spirit that
generates the culture should be super
superordinate to the spirit of the
culture.
It's something like that and that's also
why I think that one of the brilliant
discoveries,
let's say,
of Western individualistic civilization
is that the group is there to serve the
individual because the individual is the
thing that revivified the group,
so each depend on the other integrally,
but if you subordinate the individual to
the group,
then the group stagnates and dies and so
that's a very bad longterm strategy.
Even though the group and belonging to
the group is clearly necessary.
You need to uphold the values of the
group,
but the values of the group should be
subordinated to producing the individual
who gives the group vision.
And the Mesopotamians figured that out.
The Egyptians figured that out.
We've figured it out.
We just don't know that we figured it
out and it's not a mere arbitrary
supposition.
Alright,
so I should show you because this is
actually interesting.
I think perhaps
good.
I want to show you what the cosmology,
what people considered,
because the structure of the initial
order,
because it's kind of interesting and God
said,
let there be a firmament in the midst of
the waters and let it divide the waters
from the waters and God made the
firmament and divided the waters which
were under the firmament from the waters
which were above the firmament,
and it was so God called the firmament
heavens and the evening and the morning
were the second day.
Well,
so what are they thinking about?
that's the sort of classical view of the
world.
It's something like that is that there's
a desk,
it's the disc we inhabit and there's
land that's the desk,
and under the desk there's water,
fresh water,
and then under that there's the ocean.
And then on top of that there's a dome
and that's the sky.
That's the firmament,
that's heaven.
And there's water above that.
Well obviously because it rains,
so there has to be water up there.
So that's the way the cosmos was
conceptualized.
Just so you know.
Now it's a phenomenal logical
conceptualization because that's what it
looks like,
right?
And you might say,
well that's wrong.
It's like,
well,
yes,
it's,
it's wrong in a functional sort of way.
It's right from a phenomenological
perspective,
but it's wrong from a,
from a scientific perspective,
was never designed to be a scientific
perspective,
so all right,
so we won't bother with this part will.
We'll start here so god makes animals
and plants and all of that,
and then at the end of it,
this is on which day,
Sixth Day God said,
let us make man in our image after our
likeness and let them have dominion over
the fish of the sea and the fowl of the
air over the cattle and all of the
earth,
and over every creeping thing that
creepeth upon the earth.
Okay,
well,
the relevant.
There's two relevant issues there.
One is let us make man in our image
after our likeness.
Well,
what exactly does that mean?
While we've already,
we've already encountered that to some
degree,
we've already encountered what the
nature of the spirit of God is in this
story.
The nature of the spirit of God that
creates order out of chaos is the thing
that creates order out of chaos,
and so the statement here is that
there's something about human beings
that partakes in that.
Now,
when I started unpacking this,
I thought,
okay,
look,
there's an idea that's at the root of
our legal system,
and so our legal system is the
articulation of the patterns by which we
live,
and to a fair degree,
it's,
it's an evolved system.
It's a culturally constructed system,
but it's an evolved system as well and
it's predicated on the idea that there's
something about the individual that the
law has to respect.
Well,
so the question is,
well,
is that just an arbitrary supposition?
Because that's really the question.
It's the same question as,
is Western civilization founded on
something that's a rock or is it just
founded on something that's an opinion?
Well,
it's the same question with regards to
the law.
The law assumes that there's something
about you that sovereignty,
even if you're a murderer,
you have unalienable rights now you
think that is a bloody weird thing for
any sort of system to have come up with
because the idea that if you're the
ultimate in malevolent transgressors
that you still have some sort of
sovereign value.
It's like that is such an unlikely thing
for people to think up that you really
have to think a long time about how that
might've come to be.
Well,
there's an idea here.
That's the idea is that there's
something about human beings,
men and women,
you know,
because people often complain about the
patriarchal structure of the Bible.
It's based on a misapprehension of
anthropology that was popularized by
someone named Gimbutas at Ucla,
which is for,
for for her perspective.
There's not a shred of historical
evidence,
although there's some psychological
truth in it,
in,
in Genesis,
both men and women are created in the
image of God and that's quite a
remarkable thing.
I think it's a rich,
a remarkable part of the document
because it's not what you'd expect from
a patriarchal,
you know,
from a,
from a document that was designed to do
nothing but extend the domain of the
patriarchy.
It's like you left with the damn cattle
that would've made things a lot easier
and that isn't what happened,
so both men and women have this image
and what's the image?
That's the image of the thing that can
order chaos and so it's necessary to
treat you as if you have intrinsic value
because the fact that you can partake in
the process of mediating between order
and chaos means that you're basically
the salvation of society.
That's what it means and so society
can't impose on you to to greater degree
because you are too valuable for even
the law to push arbitrarily past a
certain point.
Now then you have to think this,
and this is,
this is,
this is where you really have to think
about what you believe.
Do you believe that or not?
Because there's not much difference
really technically speaking.
There's not much difference than that.
Between that and believing these
stories,
it depends bloody well what you mean by
belief.
They're not scientific representations
of an evolutionary process.
Obviously the people who came up with
them,
words,
scientists,
so whatever they are,
they're not that,
but they're making a proposition that's
not an accidental proposition and we
know that partly because it's rooted so
deeply in these ancient stories.
We have no idea how old the Mesopotamian
story is.
You know,
it's the oldest story we have in written
form,
so we know that,
but God only knows how old it is.
It's part of an oral tradition and these
oral traditions can be
look the same.
Carver gave me a big thing called a CSO
Udl,
and it's a man in the middle of a double
headed sea serpent,
right?
So they're there.
That's 14,000
years old that came from Siberia.
It's the same bloody idea.
It's the same idea.
So these ideas aren't arbitrary.
So the question is,
well,
are they true?
Well then the question is,
what the hell do you mean by true?
Because the comes down to that.
Is it true that habitable order is
dependent on the spirit that moves into
the unknown and takes the Leviathan and
chops it into pieces and distributes it
and answer to that is yes,
that's true.
As far as I can tell you mean is it
literally true?
While it's is true as things get.
That's how we got here.
We got here because people went into the
unknown,
they conquered what was out there.
They took what was of utility from that.
They brought it back and they shared it
with the community.
That's why we're here.
That is the central story of humankind
and that's still what we do.
You know,
we're not exactly necessarily going out
to conquer an embodied monster,
although we do that.
If we hunt for example,
but you know,
most of us don't do that anymore,
but to the degree that you're an
explorer in the,
in the intellectual realm,
you're still going out into the unknown
and conquering what's out there looming
like maybe it's the cure for a disease
you're looking at right in the face.
You're trying to decompose it and break
it into its parts.
You're trying to understand it and then
you're trying to tell everybody what you
found while and everybody pats you on
the back.
It says,
well,
you're,
you're a brave explorer of the unknown.
While that is exactly the sort of thing
that we should be fostering,
and it's the thing that we all admire,
so okay,
so that happens on the sixth day and so
now we know human beings are made in
God's image.
Well,
what does that mean exactly?
I think,
I think what it means a reasonable way
of thinking about it.
You can take about it like the genie.
The genie has this tremendous amount of
power that's constrained in a very small
space and genie and genius or the same
word roughly speaking.
So the genius is the.
Your genius is the genie that inhabits
you,
right?
It's this logo spirit.
It's an gets put in a very small
container.
You see that idea represented in the
Christian conception of the relationship
between Christ and God because there's
an idea that God had to empty himself
out in order to fit into the body of
Christ.
It's something like that.
They call that Kenosis,
that's a technical word and what it
seems to be the idea that you're a
lawyer.
It's like you're a low resolution
representations of the ultimate spirit
that encounters the unknown.
It's something like that.
It's a very smart idea,
and you could say maybe that's what
human beings have in common is that that
that reached an embodiment of that
spirit,
for lack of a better word.
So okay,
so then God makes the god makes human
beings male and female,
makes them in his own image and is happy
about them and says,
well,
you're going to dominate the world,
which people like David Suzuki read that
to say you should go out and dominate
the world because they read that kind of
patriarchal oppression into the text,
but this is more a description of how
things are going to be.
Then whether or not they should be that
way.
So anyways,
that's the sixth day.
The seventh day
God rests,
right?
So that's the origin of the week,
roughly speaking.
So,
okay,
that's one story.
There's two creation stories in genesis
and they actually don't match completely
in their structure.
And what happened was someone they
called the redactor,
maybe it was a bunch of people we don't
know,
to a creation story,
one and creation story too from
different places and thought,
well these are sort of the same and
they're sort of different and people are
going to be unhappy if we dispense with
this one and they're going to be unhappy
if we dispense this,
this one,
but they don't make sense together.
So let's see if we can put them in some
kind of order that makes approximate
sense.
And they took the newer one and put it
second and took the.
Sorry,
they took the older one and put it
second and put,
took the newer one and put it first.
So Adam and eve is an older story than
the story that I just told you.
So.
But it's a different story.
It's written in a different style,
but it's been more or less brought into
narrative coherence with the first
story.
So.
And you could say at the level of the
sentence,
there is paradoxes,
but at the level of the chapter,
let's say the stories make sense.
So okay,
so what happens up there went from the
earth,
a mist,
and it watered the whole face of the
ground and the Lord God formed man of
the dust of the ground and breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul.
There's an identity in this archaic sort
of thought between breath and spirit,
right respiration,
spirit,
inspiration,
pneuma like pneumatic tire spirit.
The breath contains the spirit.
Well,
why is that?
Well?
Because when people die,
the breath leaves their body,
and so it's an easy thing to identify
that with the animating spirit.
Right now,
anima means spirit as well.
So,
so that's the phenomenological reality
of the story.
And Lord God planted a garden eastward
in Eden and there he put the man whom he
had formed.
Eden means well watered place.
Well,
why?
where do you want to live?
These are desert people,
right?
Who are writing this?
Well,
what do they want?
They want an oasis.
What's an.
What's an oasis?
It's a garden with water.
While you're gonna you're gonna live
somewhere.
It's not going to be out in the middle
of the damn desert.
You want to be in a garden that's
watered,
and then you could say you also be in a
walled garden that's protected and
that's what paradise means.
Paradise.
A means walled garden.
So this initial paradise is a walled
garden.
Why?
Walled order culture,
nature.
What does it mean?
Well,
that's the natural environment of human
beings.
It's.
It's the optimal balance between culture
and nature.
That's what a walled garden is,
with enough water flowing in it to keep
it,
to keep it fertile and that water is
also chaos,
right?
There has to be.
It can't be static and dry and solid and
stale.
There has to be some living element to
it,
so.
So it's a walled place that the water
can still fruit,
defy
and out of the ground made the Lord God
to grow every tree that is pleasant to
the sight.
So it's also full of trees.
This is our natural habitat and good for
food.
The tree of life also in the midst of
the garden and the tree of the knowledge
of good and evil.
So these are two trees,
they bring forth fruit that produced
something.
One produces the knowledge of good and
evil and the other producers eternal
life.
So why?
Well,
I'll get to that emit and a river went
out of Eden to water the garden and from
dance it was parted and became into
foreheads.
We won't bother with that.
So now God has having a little chat with
Adam and he says,
look,
you can eat every tree of the garden
except one of the tree of the knowledge
of good and evil.
You don't eat that because in the day
you eat,
you'll surely die.
So you might ask,
well,
why is the tree put there to begin with?
And well the answer to that is who the
hell knows?
That's how the story portrays it and we
don't know.
And the Lord God said,
it is not good that the man should be
alone.
I will make a help meet for him and out
of the ground,
the Lord God formed every beast,
the field and every fall
of the year and brought them unto Adam
to see what he would call them and
whatsoever Adam called every living
creature that was the name thereof.
So that's an echo of the idea of the
power of the word.
Right.
So even though these stories are from
different traditions,
they're separate traditions.
You see at the beginning that God uses
his word to bring order out of chaos.
And then he allows Adam in some sense to
do the same thing is that there's this
unarticulated plethora of being and the
man comes along and says that's that.
That's that.
And that brings them into a higher order
form of being.
So it's a.
it's a replication of the creation in a,
in a shrunken form.
And Adam gave names to all the cattle
cattle or just anything that has four
legs roughly speaking and to the fowl of
the air and to every beast of the field.
But for Adam,
there was not found to help meet for
him.
And the Lord God caused a deep sleep to
fall upon Adam and he slept,
and he took one of his ribs and closed
up the flesh instead thereof.
And the rib,
which the Lord God had taken from
manmade,
he a woman and brought her unto the man.
And Adam said,
this is now bone of my bones and flesh
of my flesh.
She shall be called woman because she
was taken out of man.
And then there's an injunction,
therefore a man shall leave his father
and his mother and shall cleave unto his
wife.
And they shall be one flesh,
while there's also a,
there's a moral injunction there.
And so the idea is that the two beings
that have been created are actually not
whole until they're one thing.
Right?
And once they're joined together,
that's supposed to be one thing.
And that one thing is actually a more
perfect entity than the two things that
are a part.
So.
And that's actually part of the sacred
basis of the idea of,
of monogamous relationships in western
culture.
And they were both naked,
the man and his wife and were not
ashamed.
A crucial piece of information.
So what exactly does that mean?
Well,
the first question is what does it mean
to be naked?
And so that's something that I thought
about a lot in relationship and there's
a relationship there with shame.
So the first question is what does it
mean to be naked?
And the second question is what does it
mean to be not ashamed of that?
While there's an.
There is a,
I would say there an implication of a
kind of unconsciousness.
So Adam and Eve existed in this paradise
state,
but they don't.
They don't.
They don't have the capacity for self
reflection there no selfconsciousness
here.
Well,
why would I say that?
Because there's very little difference
between self consciousness and shame.
In fact,
if you do psychometric analysis of the
state of self consciousness,
it loads with neuroticism,
so loads with anxiety and emotional
pain.
So to become self conscious,
what does it mean to become self
conscious?
It becomes,
it means you become aware.
One way of thinking about it as you
become aware of your vulnerability or
another is that you become aware of your
insufficiency.
Okay,
so let's say that you're standing up in
front,
a crowd talking
and you become self conscious.
What happens?
Well first of all,
you can't talk anymore.
The second is he kind of fall inside.
The third is you feel ashamed,
and the fourth is that you retreat and
you look down,
so it's a low status operation and it's
associated with heightened anxiety and
so then you might say,
well,
why would you become self conscious
before a crowd?
Well,
the answer is they can see you,
right,
and they can judge you and you can make
an error in front of them and you can
make a fool of yourself so they put you
down.
You can.
You can display yourself in a manner
that ratchets you down the dominance
hierarchy.
That's to become self conscious and so
well at least you have the advantage of
being covered up in front of the crowd,
but let's say all of a sudden you're
stripped of your clothes.
So what's the problem with that?
Well,
all of your insufficiencies,
let's say are on painful display.
You can be evaluated by everyone,
but even more importantly than that,
if possible,
is that close to actually protect the
most vulnerable parts of you.
Human beings are upright animals,
right?
We're very strange animals.
You take a cat or a dog,
they're basically armored.
The part of them that you see their back
is heavily armored,
heavily protected human being stretched
upright,
and so the softest part of parts of us
are there for display,
but also were displayed as sexual
creatures too,
and so to become,
to be naked and not ashamed of it is to
lack self consciousness.
So the idea is that the Adam and eve in
the original state in the garden lacks
self consciousness.
Now the serpent was more subtle.
Subtle is an interesting word here
because it means kind of foglight and
vague and difficult to detect.
So it's something that that lurks in is
hidden.
So that's what the serpent is.
It's in the domain of hidden things than
any beast of the field,
which the Lord God had made.
And the serpent said unto the woman,
Hey,
hasn't.
God said you shouldn't eat of every tree
of the garden.
And the woman said,
we may eat of the fruit,
of the trees,
of the garden,
but of the fruit of the tree,
which is in the middle of the garden,
the central fruit,
God has said,
[inaudible] shall not eat of it.
Neither shall you touch it,
lest you die.
The serpent said unto the woman,
you shall not surely die for God knows
that in the day you eat thereof,
then your eyes will be opened and you
will be as gods knowing good and evil.
All right?
So there's another implication there.
We already saw that there's an impact.
There's the implication that Adam and
eve are not self conscious and now
there's the implication that their eyes
aren't open or at least that they're
not.
They're not open fully in some sense
they're not open,
for example,
to the knowledge of good and evil.
And that seems to be associated somehow
with death in some strange way.
Okay?
So,
and it's the serpent talking to the
woman.
So the serpent is that is the
temperature of the woman.
So the question is,
why in the world would that be?
I showed you those representations of
Mary holding the infant up in air with
her foot on the snake,
and so you think,
well,
who's more self conscious,
women or men,
and the answer to that is women are more
self conscious than meant and even
further you might say that women taught
men to be self conscious and I believe
that to be the case.
Maybe babies taught women to be self
conscious,
but women taught men to be self
conscious and they still teach them that
all the time because there's nothing
that makes a man more self conscious
that to be rejected by a woman that he
desires.
So the woman is always offering
selfconsciousness demand and it isn't
necessarily a gift that they exactly
appreciate and that Motif of course runs
through the Adam and Eve story centrally
because eve is damned forever in some
sense for making them self conscious.
Well,
he didn't want to be self conscious.
Things were pretty good when his eyes
were closed and new is wandering around.
Not worrying about whether he was naked
or not.
Well,
the women became self conscious.
Why?
Because of snakes.
Well,
maybe right.
Maybe that's exactly what happened,
you know,
she imagined we're being preyed upon for
millions of years by predatory reptiles.
Right,
and we become more and more alert to
threat and more and more alert to threat
and then one day we get so alert to
threat that we can see threat lurking in
the future and then all of a sudden we
become aware of the future and then we
become aware of death and then we're
really self conscious,
but it's pretty good if you want to keep
the snakes down,
which we've been doing quite
successfully ever since then,
but it's a big price to pay.
We got so damn sensitive to threat that
we were finally able to conceive the
ultimate threat,
not proximal threats,
but the fact of threat itself.
The fact of mortality itself and the
fact of finitude itself and maybe women
learned that because they become
painfully aware of the mortal
limitations of their infants first.
Right?
This small thing could die,
could end,
and it'll certainly as an object of
predation,
and you can imagine God only knows how
many infants human beings last to
predators.
I mean,
I told you at one point I believe that
there was a cat that was found that that
had a,
that had a,
had a skull and jaws that were
specialized for biting the skulls of
protocol.
Humans one long tooth at the back that
would drive right through the back of
the skull so the cat could put its teeth
here and drive the tooth right into the
back of the skull so you know that's a
good enough dragon for are for all
intents and purposes,
I would say.
Anyways,
the snake comes along and opens the
woman's eyes.
When the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eye and it treated to be desired
to make one wise,
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her and he did eat and the eyes of both
of them were opened and they knew that
they were naked and they sewed fig
leaves together and made themselves
aprons.
While there's a lot happening in those
few lines,
now there's a fruit thing going on
there,
snake and fruit.
Okay,
so we know from Lynn is bell
hypothetically,
that the reason that primates like us
developed our intense vision is because
we evolve with snakes.
The snakes opened her eyes.
What about fruit color vision,
right?
Why to detect ripe fruit.
We know that and our women and ripe
fruit the same.
Well,
they're the same in so far as it was
women offering the ripe fruit and that's
undoubtedly something that happened.
You know,
the hypothetical idea is the males
haunted bring home protein.
The women gather.
What are they gathering?
Well,
they're gathering at at minimum ripe
fruit and then what are they doing?
They're sharing it.
Well,
you also bring about a moral obligation
when you're sharing food,
right?
There's an invitation to reciprocity
there,
and so the fact that women were sharing,
let's say ripe fruit with men also
brings them into there.
What would you call builds up the basis
for the potential of a reciprocal moral
obligation.
It's something like that,
and the problem again for men with being
allied with women and infants is that it
also heightens their self consciousness
because you're a lot tougher and more
indomitable safe.
There's just you,
but as soon as you have a wife say,
and then you also have an infant while
all the burden of their self
consciousness and their vulnerability is
placed upon you,
well,
it's a hell of a bargain.
Well,
why did men except the bargain?
it's partly because women stood in front
of them offering them fruit,
right?
Well,
prior to the price that the men paid for
that was to wake the hell up.
Well,
who the hell wants that?
It's a lot more.
It's a lot more calming to remain asleep
with no knowledge of the sort of burden
of mortality that you would bear if you
became self conscious.
So fine.
So now they're done with it.
They,
the snake and the fruit woke them up and
they can see and the scales drop from
the rise and so we can really see.
Well,
so what does that mean?
Half our brain is visual is devoted to
visual processing,
so as well,
as long as,
as her eyes got better,
our brain got bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger.
What happens when it gets big enough?
Well,
not only can you see,
you can see it,
you can start to see into the future.
Well,
that's exactly what happened to us.
Not only could we see with her eyes,
we could see with our imagination and
our imagination is our are.
You can see with your eyes closed,
right?
Close your eyes,
bring up a vision.
You can imagine the future.
Well,
what are you seeing?
You're seeing a potential future with
your eyes closed,
the circuitries there.
Once it's developed,
you can use it to imagine.
You can project your project,
your vision into places that don't even
exist and you can start to conceptualize
the future.
What happens when you conceptualize the
future?
Well,
this is a.
I'm spoiling the punchline.
You have to work because you can see the
future coming.
You Think,
oh,
the future's coming.
It isn't just the present anymore.
I don't have to just worry about whether
or not I'm hungry right now.
I'm going to have to worry about whether
I'm hungry tomorrow and next week and
next month and next year,
and for me and for my wife and for my
child and for the community.
It's like you can forget about your day
to day existence in paradise.
At that point,
there's no evidence that people in
industrialized societies are happier
than people in non industrialized
societies.
In fact,
quite the contrary.
We're less happy.
Why?
Well,
because we fully and constantly bear the
burden of the future.
Well,
that's good because we don't die and we
lived maybe 30 years longer and we have
fewer horrible diseases and all of that,
but that doesn't mean it's any picnic.
You have to carry that along with you
wherever you go.
That's the burden of self consciousness,
right?
And that's exactly what happens when God
finds out that Adam and eve have become
self conscious.
The one of the first things he says is
jigs up now,
man,
you're going to be working forever
toiling forever.
It's your destiny.
There's no escaping from it.
Well,
human beings work.
What does that mean?
They sacrifice the present for the
future,
and that's partly as soon as this
happens,
the next story,
which is cain and enable,
you see the Motif of sacrifice emerge,
right?
That story circulates around the Motif
of sacrifice,
sacrifice the present for the future.
Well,
what's the price you pay?
You don't get the present.
That's a big price,
right?
Because what you do is what you're doing
essentially is you're taking all the
potential suffering of the future and
putting it into the present all the
time.
Well,
so what happens?
maybe you live longer and live
healthier,
but you're not without the burden that
that puts on you.
So the eyes of them were both opened and
they knew they were naked.
Well,
so what does that mean?
what is naked mean?
It means you know you're vulnerable.
That's exactly what it means.
They know they're vulnerable.
So they sewed fig leaves together and
make themselves aprons.
So what happens is they wake up,
their eyes open,
they know they're vulnerable,
so they discover the future.
They discover their vulnerability
extended into the future,
and the first thing they do is build
culture,
right?
That's the fig leaves.
It's like,
okay,
here's the vulnerability.
We put a barrier between us and the
world.
It's like a wall,
right?
Because this is externalized clothing.
That's one way of thinking about it,
and so to put that clothing on,
this is clothing as a human universal,
by the way.
Now sometimes it's only used for
decorative purposes,
but far more often,
especially in cold climates,
it's used for protection,
so to clothe yourself is to recognize
your vulnerability and to use culture to
hold it at bay.
So fine.
They made themselves aprons and they
heard the voice of the Lord God walking
in the garden in the cool of the day,
and Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord God among
the trees of the garden.
Okay?
So before Adam and eve wake up,
before they realize they're vulnerable,
they don't hide from God.
So what does that mean?
Well,
he's the spirit that goes into the
unknown to,
to,
to conquer it,
and to make the world.
Okay?
So let's say that's what you're supposed
to do.
You're supposed to mediate between chaos
and order.
Okay?
And you were supposed to do that
forthrightly,
so then the question is what the Hell's
stopping you?
And that answer's easy.
Your knowledge of your vulnerability.
Obviously that's what stopping you.
It's like,
why aren't you courageous and
forthright?
Well,
because you can be cut off at the knees
and terribly hurt and so you're going to
shrink back from that responsibility and
it's no bloody wonder,
right?
It's obviously what's going to happen.
So the Lord God calls them to Adam.
So He's trying to.
What that means for the,
for God to call on you is to say for God
to say,
I'm I want to act through you or I want
to act with you.
Have that spirit.
Let's say.
Well,
Adam says,
I heard,
I heard God says to Adam,
where are you?
Adam says,
I heard your voice in the garden,
right?
I heard the call,
but I was afraid because I was naked and
I hid myself.
It's like,
yes,
that's exactly what human beings are
like.
That's precisely exactly what we're
We hear the call,
but we hide and we have.
The thing is it's.
There's good reason for it.
It's not something trivial and God said,
who told you you were naked?
Did you eat the tree that I told you you
shouldn't eat?
And the man says the man doesn't come
off very well in this particular phrase
as far as I'm concerned,
and there's actually quite.
This is actually quite a comedic story
except that it's also a catastrophic
tragedy.
It's like God calls out him out like,
what's with you now?
You know you're hiding from me.
Why?
And the first thing out of him does it
says it's her fault.
It's her fault.
She made me self conscious.
Well,
I see that in resentful.
Men All the time.
They're very antipathetic towards women
and they blame their misery and
resentment on the fact that women won't
have anything to do with them while the
women are making them self conscious for
not being old.
They should be because the women think,
why should I bother with you if you're
not the embodiment of the spirit that
will move into the unknown and and face
the Leviathan,
which is exactly what she should be
saying.
And you're thinking,
well,
I don't want to have anything to do with
that,
but I'd like women to like me anyways.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that.
So that doesn't work out.
And so instead of getting your act
together,
you say those God damn women,
that's exactly what Adam says to God.
He said,
well,
don't,
don't be laying this on my feet.
It's the woman you made her.
She made me all self conscious and
cowardly.
It's like brilliant,
great,
wonderful.
And God says to the woman,
what did you do?
And the woman said,
well,
it was,
it was the serpent that confused me and
I ate well.
It's like,
actually I'm a little more sympathetic
to her then dad,
I'm all things considered because after
all she was trying to deal with the damn
snake.
Right?
And we find out that the snake is not
only the thing that preys upon her
infants,
but as the tradition develop,
it's identified with Satan himself.
So,
and that's the snake in every soul.
That's the right way of thinking about
that.
So she had her reasons,
but doesn't matter.
You pay whether you have your reasons or
not,
and so God says to the serpent,
because you've done this,
you're cursed above all cattle,
above every beast of the field,
upon the Belize,
shelled out,
go and dust shelled out,
eat all the days of thy life.
So first of all,
the serpent seems to have legs,
right?
And then it's turned into a snake and
that's actually how it worked by the
way,
because snakes had legs and they lost
them.
Now I'm not trying to say that this
story necessarily represents that,
but it's an interesting parallel and he
tells the snake,
I'll put enmity between the and the
woman and between thy seed and her seed,
it shall bruise thy head and Thou shall
bruise his heel.
While yes,
well that's the snake striking.
Great.
And the fact that when human being see
snakes,
they want to just like the simpsons
whacking day,
right?
It's time to get rid of the snakes and
that's why the many great saints are
those who drive the snakes from the land
like St Patrick or St George and the
Dragon,
and it's the same representation of the
hero moving out into the Wilderness and
confronting the predatory,
the predatory predatory potential is the
right way of thinking about it.
All right unto the woman he said,
I will greatly multiply thy sorrow and
thy conception in sorrow,
thou shalt bring forth children and that
desire to be shall be to thy husband and
he shall rule over thee.
Well.
That's a statement of destiny,
not a statement of the way it should be.
So what does it mean?
I will greatly multiply thy sorrow and
die conception,
while self consciousness will do that,
because of course women are fully aware
of exactly how fragile their infants
are.
So that's a big problem in sorrow.
Thou shalt bring forth children.
That's something particular to human
women,
right?
And here's why,
the price we paid for the rapid
expansion of our brain,
which is also something that gave us
this self consciousness and vision meant
that there's an evolutionary arms race
between the pelvic width of women and
the hole in the center of the pelvis and
the infants had.
So what happens is the infant is born
far too young for a mammal of our size
because if it was benny older,
the head would be too big,
the pelvis would have to be too wide,
it's structural stability would be
compromised and then women couldn't run.
So right now women are at the maximum
for hip width in terms of their ability
to run.
So what's happened is that infants have
had to be born younger with a
compressible head.
So you know,
the bones of an infant scholar joined
together and sometimes after babies are
born,
their head is actually almost cone
shaped because of the tremendous
pressure that was exerted on their head
during the,
during the birthing process.
And of course that's killed innumerable
women,
right?
I mean women's life expectancy before
what?
The latter half of the 20th century was
way below men because they died in
childbirth all the time and why?
Well,
it's a.
it's a very,
what do you call that?
It's a.
it's.
It's a very narrow gateway and the price
that women pay for it is very high risk
of death,
very high risk of sorrow because of
death of children in childbirth and also
extraordinarily extraordinary pain in
giving birth,
so that's the price women pay for having
vision and being self conscious while
that's and then worse,
they desire their husband and he will
rule over the well.
Whether or not that's good or bad,
it doesn't matter.
God's statement is that's how it's going
to be.
Well,
partly that's because as far as I can
tell,
there isn't really women.
Roughly speaking,
there's women with infants and a woman
with an infant is compromised in terms
of her what?
Independent individuality to a
remarkable degree because the infant is
dependent,
absolutely dependent,
absolutely dependent for a year and then
unbelievably dependent for like eight
years after that and then still pretty
dependent for another five.
So once you have an infant,
it's no longer you and I've talked to
lots of women for whom that was a great
relief by the way,
because it actually is somewhat of a
relief to now not be the center of
everything.
You know,
if you go visit your in laws for
example,
and you have a baby,
it's like they pay attention to the
baby.
Your parents will do the same thing.
It's kind of Nice to have that happen,
but it's still an absolute catastrophe
for you as an independent being and
you're not getting out in the forest and
hunt down dragons when you have an
infant.
So even if you could do it,
you're not going to do it.
And so that's basically what that
statement outlines.
And then to Adam,
he says,
because you listened to your wife and
ate of that tree,
which I said,
you know,
maybe that's not such a good idea.
Curse it is the ground for the sake in
sorrow.
Show thou eat of it all the days of the
light of thy life.
Thorns also and thistles shall it bring
forth to thee.
And now she'll eat.
The herb of the field in the sweat of
thy face shall thou eat bread til thou
return into the ground.
That's the death part for out of it.
Was Thou taken for dust,
thou art and unto dust thou shalt thou
return and I missed one thing about
that.
When the serpent,
this took me a long time to figure out.
I think I've mentioned it already,
but it's worth reviewing.
The serpent tells eve that if she eats
from the fruit of the tree,
then her eyes will be open and shall be
as gods.
Knowing good and evil.
Well serpent doesn't say,
well,
you'll be as as gods in so far as new
and good and evil,
but you'll die so you only get half the
gift.
And so then I thought,
well,
there's this weird minter mangling of of
occurrences in the story.
There's the development of vision.
There's the development of self
consciousness.
There's the knowledge of nakedness,
there's the emergence of work,
there's the emergence of pain and
suffering and childbirth,
and there's knowledge of good and evil
thought for ages.
I thought,
what the hell?
What the hell?
What's going on there?
Why is there an emphasis on moral
knowledge?
What does this have to do with moral and
the implication is that in the initial
state of unconsciousness,
there was no moral knowledge and I think
of that as an animal like state,
right?
There's no moral knowledge in animals.
You don't think while that evil cat,
you don't ever think that even if it's
acting like a Predator,
even if it's playing with its prey,
you don't attribute moral knowledge to
the cat because you say,
well,
it doesn't know what it's doing.
It doesn't understand what it's doing,
which is to say it acted out,
but it can't represent it or maybe even
more.
It acts it out,
but it can't represent it and it
certainly can't analyze its
representation.
It doesn't have that level of capacity,
but we do so there's that's associated
with moral knowledge to some degree.
Why knowledge of good and evil.
I thought,
all right,
here's what it is.
Let's think about what you would
consider reprehensible.
Universally.
You could say,
how's this torturing and infant?
I would consider that virtually
universally reprehensible,
wouldn't you say?
Okay,
so we will accept that as a reasonable
definition,
so then the question is,
one,
why would you do it?
We'll leave that aside for a moment to
how do you know how to do it?
That's the issue and that's easy.
Once I know how I can be hurt because
I'm aware of my own vulnerability,
I know how you can be hurt and I can
make it into a game and I can prolong it
forever and I can do it the worst
possible way,
and that's why when you open your eyes
and you know your vulnerability and your
nakedness,
that you immediately have the knowledge
of good and evil and so then evil
becomes something like,
while there's tragedy in life,
fine earthquakes,
cancer disease,
all those terrible things that's
different than me deciding that I'm
going to make you miserable.
The one is while you're a limited
creature in an unlimited world,
you're going to get hurt because of that
and maybe there's ways that you can be
that will enable you to transcend that
at least to some degree and still have
the benefits of being.
That's entirely different than me
deciding that things are going to go a
lot worse for you than they might and
human beings are capable.
I don't know if you've ever gone to some
of the dungeon porcher dungeons in
Europe.
Boy,
those are fun places to go.
You think you take the most malevolent
person you possibly could then have a
little convention of those people and
then get them to think up the worst
possible things that they could possibly
devise and then you have the instruments
of torture that in euro,
in a medieval torture dungeon,
right?
It's an art form and you think,
well,
why do people,
why are people willing to inflict that
on one another?
Well,
and we'll talk about that next time when
we talk about the story of Cain and Abel
because I think it holds the secret to
that,
and in the meantime,
I'll stop with this story,
but I want to tell you the story of the
Buddha because it maps onto it very
nicely.
So what do you have?
You have.
You have a protected space.
There's unconscious beings in a
protected space.
Something comes in in the form of the
serpent to reveal death to reveal
vulnerability,
death,
right?
And then the paradise comes to an end.
The human beings are eliminated from it
and they don't get to come back.
So God puts angels with flaming swords
at the,
at the gateway to Paradise so that
people cannot come back in and it isn't
obvious what that means except that
there's gotta be some sort of trial by
fire before reentering paradise.
But we can leave that alone for a
moment.
So that's the basic structure of the
story.
Unconscious human beings,
emergence of knowledge,
realization of death and suffering and
the elimination of the paradise.
Right?
Okay.
So now I'll read you the story of the
Buddha,
the father of Prince Gautama,
the Buddha savior of the Orient,
determined to protect his son from
desperate knowledge and tragic awareness
built for him and enclosed pavilion,
a walled garden of earthly delights.
Okay?
So the story goes that at angel visited
Buddhist father and said that he's going
to have a son and the son is either
going to become the greatest ruler that
the world has ever seen or a spiritual
leader and the father being a practical
man thought where there's no bloody way.
I want my son to be some like wandering
spiritual leader.
I want him to be the greatest king that
the world has ever seen.
Okay?
And so the father decides,
how am I going to get my son to be the
greatest ruler of the world has ever
seen.
I better get them to fall in love with
the world because then he's not going to
go traipsing after some sort of half
witted spiritual knowledge.
He's going to stick to practical tasks,
right?
That's something that a father should do
to some degree is orient you in the
world,
right?
And maybe shouldn't subvert your
spiritual development to any great
degree,
but there's a practical element to this
and,
and so anyways,
that's how it works.
And so that's what happens.
The father bill is this city of
perfection and he eliminates from it
everything that's a reminder of the
suffering that's associated with life,
so the only thing that's allowed,
the only creatures that are allowed to
be in there,
the only people that are allowed to be
in there are healthy,
young,
and happy people,
so the Buddha grows up surrounded by
nothing but the positive elements of
life.
While you think,
well,
what does that mean?
While it's akin to the paradise idea,
obviously walled closure of paradise
where there's no death,
but there's more to it than that too.
It's also in some sense what a good
father would do.
What do you do with your young children?
Well,
you don't expose them to death and decay
at every step of the way.
Right to you.
You build a protected world for them
like a wall enclosure,
and you only keep what's healthy and
life giving inside of it and you don't
expose them to things that they can't
tolerate.
You know,
maybe you don't take a three year old to
a funeral now.
Maybe you do,
but maybe you don't.
There's things that you don't expect
them to be able to cope with.
You regulate what they're allowed to
watch.
You're not going to show them the tech
Texas chainsaw massacre when they're
four years old,
right,
so so you're staving off knowledge of
mortality and death,
and so he's just being a good father in
many ways here.
All signs of decay and degeneration
where thus kept hidden from the prince,
immersed in the immediate pleasures of
the senses in physical love and dance
and music and beauty and pleasure.
Gautama grew to maturity,
protected absolutely from the
limitations of mortal being.
However,
he grew curious despite his father's
most particular attention and will and
resolve to leave his seductive present.
Well,
it's that curiosity element.
It's the same thing that lurks in the
Adam and Eve story.
It's like God tells Adam and Eve,
see that tree over there.
Don't be bothered with it.
Well,
you know what's going to happen with
human beings,
especially if there's a snake associated
with it.
They're going to be over there right
away.
Check in that place out,
and that's exactly what happens with the
Buddha.
It's like he's raised to be healthy and
what is,
what's the consequence of that is that
the fact that he's healthy makes them
look for what's beyond the protected
confines of the thing that made him
healthy.
It's like even in the Japan story,
you know where Japan Paints on
Pinocchio,
his mouth,
and he's ready to go.
He puts them outside the next day and
Pinocchio is ready to run away with all
the kids.
Right?
So the consequence of raising a child in
a healthy way is that the child is going
to be curious enough to go out there and
look for some trouble and we actually
know that because there is followup
studies of teenagers.
You imagine that there's teenagers who
never break any rules and then there's
teenagers who break all the rules.
Okay?
These teenagers don't do very well.
Introverted,
depressed,
anxious,
depressed.
Sorry.
I said that twice.
These ones are antisocial.
The ones in the middle.
That's what you want.
You want your damn teenager to get out
of the paradisical confines of your
house and to go cause some trouble and
to investigate.
Maybe you don't want to know about it
anymore than you have to.
You don't want them to be breaking rules
all the time and you don't want them to
be so timid into a press that they can't
make a move on their own and never make
a mistake.
So the paradoxical thing here,
and it's sort of echoed are this is why
I like these two stories back to back is
like if you give people what they want,
then the first thing they're gonna do is
try to get beyond it.
And Dostoevsky says the same thing and
notes from underground.
He says,
if you gave people everything they
wanted,
pure utopia.
So he says,
so that they're sitting in a pool of
bliss with nothing but bubbles of
happiness coming up from the surface and
all they have to do is eat cake and busy
themselves with the continuation of the
species.
Dusty said,
Dostoyevsky's observation is the first
thing that people would do is find
something to smash that with.
Just so that something interesting and
perverse could happen.
It's like,
well,
yes,
we're,
we're creatures that are designed to
encounter the unknown.
We want to keep moving beyond what we
have,
even if we have what we have is what we
want,
and maybe that's partly because we're
oriented towards the future.
We think,
well this is great,
but it's not good enough.
It's great,
There's always something more that
drives us forward.
While.
So that's what happens with the Buddha.
He gets curious.
He sees the walls,
he thinks there's walls,
there's probably something outside of
those walls.
So then he goes to his father and he
says,
I'm,
I want to go outside,
what's outside?
And his father says,
Nah,
you don't want to go outside.
And Buddha says,
yeah,
well I really do want to go outside and
his father knows that unless he lets him
go outside,
he's going to climb over the walls and
so the father decides he's going to let
them go outside.
Bugs get fixed everything out there
first.
So he goes outside.
It's like the Chinese preparing for the
Olympics,
you know when they sprayed the grass
with,
with green paint,
got rid of all the homeless people.
It's the same thing.
So he goes outside the city and he tells
everyone,
all right,
old people,
sick people dying,
people hit the road.
We don't want to see it for awhile,
clean all this out.
We want the attractive people around the
sides of the roads,
like waving palm fronds and all of that
and so when my son comes out,
he's going to see nothing but what's
good and so we get that all arranged.
He lets his son go outside.
Now his son goes outside in this little
carrier thing and he has someone with
him now,
unbeknownst to his father,
that person that's with them as an
emissary of the gods and so in a
perverse way he plays the same role as
the serpent in the story of Adam and eve
and the gods have already arranged so
that the father's a carer is going to be
insufficient and it's the snake in the
garden idea.
It's like no matter how much care you
take to make things perfect,
some of the,
some of what you're excluding is going
to come back in.
So anyways,
Buddha goes outside and he's in his
chariot and preparations were made to
guild is chosen route to cover the
adventurous path with flowers and to
display for his admiration and
preoccupation,
the fairest women of the kingdom,
the print set out with full red,
new in the shield,
the comfort of a chaperone chariot and
delighted in the Panorama previously
prepared for him.
The gods,
however,
decided to disrupt these most carefully
laid plans and sent an aged man to
hobble in full view alongside the road.
The prince's fascinated gaze fell upon
the ancient interloper,
compelled by curiosity.
He asked his attendant,
what is that creature stumbling,
shabby bent and broken beside my retinue
and the attendant answered that is a man
like other men who was born in infant
became a child,
a youth,
a husband,
a father,
a father of fathers has become old
subject to destruction of his beauty,
his will,
and the possibilities of life like other
men,
you say,
hesitantly inquired the prints.
That means this will happen to me,
and the attendant answered inevitably
with the passage of time.
Well,
that's the end of that party.
The world collapses in on Buddha and
paying he hightails at home.
Well,
what does that mean?
that's what children do.
Roughly speaking is there around their
mother there.
They've got security there.
They go out into the unknown.
They encounter something that's just a
little bit too much for them.
Bang,
they come home,
they get old,
padded back into shape,
and how been taken care of hugging
children and patting them is actually
analgesic.
It actually reduces paid.
Unsurprisingly,
that's what you do with someone who's
grieving,
right?
So you hug them because grief is paid
so,
so they,
you know,
you pat them and they get rid of their
pain.
They get rid of their anxiety.
You calm them down and what happens?
Well,
the next day they want to go out again.
that's exactly what happens to the
Buddha,
so he's all shorted out by his encounter
with death,
which has very little different than
what happens to Adam and eve runs back,
recovers for six months.
He has posttraumatic stress disorder.
He runs home and he recovers for six
months,
right in time,
his anxiety lessened.
His curiosity,
grinned.
He ventured outside again this time the
God sent a sick man interview this creek
cheerios does attendance,
shaking and palsy,
horribly afflicted,
unbearable to behold,
a source of pity and contempt.
What is he and the attendant answered
that's a man like other men
who was born whole but who became ill
and sick,
unable to cope,
a burden to himself and others suffering
and incurable like other men you say,
inquired the prince.
This could happen to me and the
attendant answers,
no man is exempt from the ravages of
disease.
Once again,
the world collapsed and Gautama returned
to his home,
but the delights of his previous life
where ash is in his mouth and he
ventured forth a third time,
the gods in their mercy sent him a dead
man in funeral procession.
This creature,
he asked his attendant laying so still
appearing,
so fearsome surrounded by grief and by
Soro last and for Lauren.
What is he?
And the attendant answered that is a man
like other men born of woman,
beloved and hated.
Who is once you.
Who once was you and now as the earth
like other men you say,
acquired the prince.
Then this could happen to me.
This is your and said the attendant and
the end of all men.
Well,
that's the end of childhood,
right?
There's no going back after that.
It's like Pinocchio goes back.
There's no one home anymore.
It's there's nothing that your father
can do to protect you from knowledge of
death.
There is no returning to the childhood
unconsciousness because you now know and
there's no going backwards.
Suicide that's going backwards.
That's how you replace your emergent
self consciousness with the old blissful
unconsciousness,
and that's exactly what suicidal people
wish they are going to destroy their
painful selfconsciousness and make it
all go away.
The world collapsed to final time and
Gautama asked to be returned home,
but the attendant had orders from the
prince's father and took them instead to
a festival of women.
Oh,
curing.
Near occurring nearby in a grove in the
woods.
The prince was met by a beautiful
assemblage who offered themselves freely
to him without restraint in song,
dance and play in the spirit of sensual
love.
But gautama could think only of death
and the inevitable decomposition of
beauty and took no pleasure in the
display.
Well,
so you see the parallels
between one story and the other.
They're the same.
They have the same underlying structure,
initial paradise,
partly childhood,
partly unconsciousness,
the emergence of knowledge of mortality
into that and the demolition of the of
the paradise is the same metal story
that we've been talking about all along
ordered state collapse into chaos while
the rest of the story is the return,
like in the Bible,
Bible is actually set up that way.
It's collapse into history and then a
movement upward.
The question is,
what's the movement upward?
That's the question here.
When the collapse is caused by knowledge
of mortality and self and the emergence
of self consciousness and knowledge of
death,
is there any manner in which redemption
can be attained or is that the final
like,
is that finally,
is that.
Does that finally demolish you?
Well,
that's the question and that's,
that's,
that's it's the answer to that question
that entire civilizations constantly
pursue and the question is,
well,
what is the answer?
And part of the answer is identification
with the spirit that generates order out
of chaos.
That's the answer.
It's something like that.
And so then the question is,
what does that mean?
Well,
that will be what the last two lectures
in the course or about,
because we're down to two last lectures,
so any questions,
does that make sense?
More,
more importantly,
really is there,
is there any way in which it doesn't
make sense because these stories are not
supposed to make sense,
right?
That's the theory is that they're
archaic superstitions or something like
that.
Well,
it doesn't seem to me that that's the
case.
It seems to me that they make insanely
perfect sense.
They're exactly right.
They tell you exactly what human beings
are like and exactly what the situation
that we face is so.
And so.
Then the question is,
well,
the diagnosis is made properly.
What has the cure been properly
identified?
Well,
that's what we'll discuss for the next
two sessions.